all right
so come on guys come back on this stream
oh my goodness what a horrible nightmare
all right let's go here comes okay
people are coming in
this is should be better now the sound
should be better everything should be
better
everybody should just be very happy and
uh
and for those who put in super chats i
have your super chats they'll be they'll
be there
even if though even if this is like the
new
if this is the new stream so all right
so
all right we're back okay
my goodness i think this is like the
curse of trying to start an hour early
which is that
it's gonna end up being the same as
before okay so now i'm going to stop i'm
totally going to stop all the
announcements
will be only for those that were there
and will not be for anybody who's tuning
in
we'll tune in to the final video and so
let's go into the questions it's been
like 15 minutes
all right here we go so i'm gonna start
with
uh the symbolic world website as people
know uh people who
kind of give ten dollars or more a month
they can ask questions in advance
and uh and if you want other questions
uh best is to go into the super chats
because there's too many questions
anyways there's always too many
questions i never
there's always i always these q and a's
are getting longer and longer
okay so fred c asks
can you explain the meaning of mary
normally wearing blue on the inside
and red on the outside in icons
i've also noted that it's sometimes
inverted and the blue is outside
especially the icon of the coronation is
there any specific meaning to this now
the thing about that is that mary
traditionally mary doesn't wear red on
the outside and blue on the inside
traditionally mary wears the
royal purple on the outside
and then then we'll maybe wear blue
have blue or red on the inside and this
is at least an orthodox icon which she
wears
but there has been like a there's like a
trope that came about
and and i think that the trope has
meaning which is that
that mary would wear uh red on the
outside blue on the inside
and then the opposite for christ where
he would have
uh red on the inside and blue on the
outside and so i think that
this is this is definitely something
which at least has
meaning structurally in terms of
the in terms of the inner and the outer
and the inside the let's say the inner
and the outer in terms of the right hand
and the left hand
but it's very intuitive and i've heard
people try to explain it and sometimes
i'm not sure i completely agree with the
way they explain it but for sure it
seems
to appear to us as a pattern which which
makes sense
you know in the sense that christ is
open is let's say a public figure is out
in public
um and so so i'll tell you often what
what people have said is that let's say
christ is divine
and then manifests himself as
um manifests himself as human
and then other people have said for mary
she's human and then she
gets united she becomes divine in
her in theosis like she's united with
god and so some people have said
something like that
and so i think that that's okay but but
it definitely structurally you can see
that there's definitely
a play on the inside and the outside
and so christ is definitely more
christ is someone who especially in his
ministry kind of hides his divinity and
then
has like a let's say has an outer
and outer uh he's very outer and then
the mother of god she's secret so it
there might be something to do with that
but i think there's i think it's one of
those things like with color
and with music where it's sometimes it's
almost
all about it's about pattern itself and
so it's it's not that it has a
narrative meaning necessarily but it
shows itself as
this flip side of opposites you know
like a yin yang let's say so when you
see a yin yang
it i mean that has more narrative
meaning but there is a sense in which
you have an inside one and an outside
other and then the inside one and
outside other so maybe the yin yang is
the best way to understand that
like you know white dot and a black in
the black shape and a black dot in a
white shape
in the sense of two opposites but which
are driven by the
the other something like that
hopefully that makes sense and it's not
completely chaotic what i just answered
okay so bill 1234 says
hi jonathan i have a question about
pride and how we're supposed to
understand it from a christian
perspective i know pride is a sin but
there is also the idea of having pride
in one's own work for example
is there something to be distinguished
or is it always wrong to have pride or
be prideful
i also wanted to know what you thought
about the contemporary worship of pride
in the modern secular
and progressive culture lgbt etc thanks
in advance for answering my question
and so i think that
i think that how can i say this
i think that pride as self-sufficiency
is definitely always
wrong i think that there are you can
have a kind of
hierarchy of pride
uh but usually it would be things that
are kind of beyond you
and so you can have a certain amount of
pride in
let's say you're in your in your nation
you can have a certain amount of pride
in the sense of being proud of being a
christian
being proud of being a canadian being
proud of being
a pajao let's say uh proud of the
lineage that my father has given me par
of
that which has been handed to me i think
that that that can
actually if we see it in a proper
hierarchy it can it can kind of
climb up you know towards a
glorification
of god you know the the difficulty is
when
this happens mostly is when you
you focus your your pride on on one spot
and you think that
there's something also about a pride in
something which is bigger than you
there's something about that which is
also not uh
the problem of pride is like
self-boasting it's it's boasting it's
like self-naming
and i mentioned this before it's trying
to give yourself
qualities and not receive them from
outside
but if let's say you're you're like
proud of your country and then
your country can honor you right so
you're proud of participating
in that country and so in that
participation then you
might receive honor from your country
like a medal if you're a
if you're a warrior or some some kind of
recognition let's say
and so then it comes from from somewhere
else it doesn't
come from yourself the problem is always
like this kind of
self adulation and and the the
the worship of oneself and the worship
of our own characteristics
um so to be honest i see that way more
in the kind of
modern pride movement which is this idea
that
this is who i am like i'm proud of who i
am
so accept me the way i am and this kind
of sense of
you know it's like i decide what i am
and you have to kind of accept it
you know this idea of self-naming and
you see that also in the weird kind of
gender stuff that's happening which is
that
the sense that it's like i'm the one who
decides what gender i am there isn't a
sense in which i have to kind of submit
to a higher pattern which is kind of
beyond me and
and which which is not which
which doesn't depend on my own wins and
my own feelings in my own
my own thinking so that's what i think
about that
so cr streets you'll ask what is the
symbolism of
elopement you mean like eloping i think
you probably mean like eloping
in the sense of uh like getting married
on your own
i guess that's what you mean um
that's an interesting i never really
thought about that but it's very
interesting
because there's something about that
for example like the idea that you can
elope
in the west is is actually a
manifestation of the notion of consent
in christian in the christian tradition
in a lot of ancient societies marriage
was a thing of families only it's like
you know you
you know you get promised to this other
family and then the families kind of
decide and they join
together for all these reasons of uh you
know of
land and wealth and and whatever
political reasons that you would
join together it's like they would make
a good marriage for you
um but in christianity there's a sense
in which
the final decision is in the people like
the individuals they have to
say yes in order for a marriage to be
valid which was not the case in like
roman times like scandinavian times dude
like a scandinavian could take a woman
and then there was no even question of
whether or not she consented it was no
there's no
asking about that uh whereas in the in
the christian tradition they really
developed this idea of the yes
which i think was based on the yes of
the of the virgin mary
at the uh at the enunciation
where where it's like she says let it be
done according to your will
and so i think that that it has to do
with that and so
so the the the thing is that young
people in
in the even like in the middle ages or
in the old
a while ago could go to a priest and ask
the priest to marry them
and the priest could marry them even
without asking permission
of their parents because if they were
you know if they were old enough in the
sense that they could reproduce then
they could they could get married um and
so i think that that's
that there's something about that in
this idea of eloping
um so you know the idea of
you know a man shall leave his family
you know that the men and women shall
leave their family and become
one one flesh there's something about
that
but it's probably still best to involve
your families in your
in your union just because it gives you
a better network
after that to kind of uh to to live with
and to
it gives you a stability it's a you know
getting married without
the permission or the not the permission
but let's say the
the participation of your family is uh
is a dangerous thing like you might it
might lead you into trouble
all right so bogdan says it seems that
the internet
rather than uniting people has made our
divisions more entrenched
people in different echo chambers often
can understand each other even when
using the same words
like they're speaking different
languages is this similar to the
confusion of languages and the tower of
babel
and and if that event stopped the
construction of the tower could the
internet somehow stop
the creation of the modern tower the
all-encompassing global system you've
mentioned before
not sure if i'm thinking about this
right but i had some intuition about it
thanks for all your work yes i think
that that's right i think that you can
understand the tower of babel
um you can almost understand it in the
simultaneity we
obviously it's a story so you have to
understand it in a sequence of events
where
the builders make the the tower and then
they then god confounds their languages
and then they don't understand each
other but you could understand it
in the sense that it's in building the
tower
that their languages get confounded and
obviously
narratively it'd be hard to to say that
but now like you said right now we have
an intuition
of how that is absolutely the case that
is that in
trying to create an identity which is
all-encompassing
and too high then what happens is
because you know there is a sense in
which people want to break down the
competing identities
they want to remove intermediary
identities you know like church
affiliation
uh kova did a lot of that right where
they want they want to have just like
one
massive affiliation to this project
and so but in doing that people end up
loop you need these intermediary
identities and so people end up
losing the things that hold real
together and in the very building of the
tower
they stop understanding each other and
then the tower breaks down
so it's actually a pretty interesting
moment to understand the tower of babel
and to understand it not as some
arbitrary thing because this is always
the problem when we read scripture
because when it says god does this or
god says this
we somehow think that it's just this
arbitrary god that comes down and does
stuff
but that's not how it work works the the
the will of
god is manifesting the reality of the
world
it's not it's not separate god is not
separate from the world
kind of imposing some arbitrary will on
it but so but it's actually manifesting
the very pattern of reality in its
proper
and its full sense and so the
understanding that
in building the tower then they would
stop understanding each other
is probably the best way to see it and
the best way to understand what's going
on right now
all right so pnumaish asks
what role can imagination have in our
lives usually imagination is frowned
upon especially in prayer
but besides creative endeavors where can
be useful in our daily lives perhaps
constantly imagining
a life that we don't have is detrimental
to ourselves but i think
there is a positive aspect to
imagination as well
i would say that this is definitely
especially in kind of the orthodox
church it's true that imagination if you
read the the
fathers like if you read the um the
desert
the let's say the hessicastic fathers
they really downplay
the idea of imagination and so they
don't want you
like you said in prayer because you know
like the jesuits for example had this
idea that
you you kind of imagine you're reading
scripture and you're praying and you
kind of imagine
you tried to picture the scene of the of
the bible and
picture jesus and picture the saints and
picture mary and stuff
and uh for sure in the orthodox
tradition this is not
this is not encouraged um
i would say that so so a good way to
a good way to maybe understand it is
that
imagination can be the place where the
patterns can imprint themselves
and so there's something in the
imagination of
a positive aspect of the imagination
that you see for example
in the orthodox tradition in terms of
the amazing
let's say iconography that was produced
the amazing architecture the the beauty
the music
all of this kind of came about
but it wasn't it wasn't about people
trying to kind of
think up of things that could be
interesting but
rather a disposition for this imaginary
imaginary the imaginary or that
that capacity of the person to
to be available for the higher patterns
that kind of imprint themselves and find
bodies so i think that that's really the
the the role
of imagination um but
it's like that's in a strict kind of
really strict
monastic sense but i think that they're
they're despite the warnings of the
fathers
i think that there is also room for kind
of everyday imagination i
i don't have a problem with fictional
stories although some
some monks might i don't have a problem
with fictional stories
you know at the outset i think that
there's a danger
in kind of giving yourself to fictional
stories but it's it's always
it's always these things where the thing
that
that is kind of far further away in the
right perspective can also be something
which is bringing you back
i think that in our world right now
fictional stories and you've seen that's
why i intro
interpret fictional stories in my uh on
my channel
can be a little step on the ladder
bringing you back
towards kind of a immediate uh
perception of reality so
that's what i think
um so david flores can you talk about
the way backgrounds are depicted in
icons
why are mountains depicted the way they
are and so uh
i mean i don't know what you mean by
backgrounds if you mean like the fact
that backgrounds are usually flat
like a flat color um
or gold let's say you i think that that
this is something that has different
interpretations george cordes has a
pretty good interpretation
of that which is the way that icons are
represented is
to have a a plane a picture plane in the
back
and then have the figures in front of
the picture plane so that
so that the figures actually kind of
come out towards you
rather than something like in the
renaissance images where they
tend to recede into the frame so this is
his explanation i don't know if that is
is reasonable and in terms of mountains
usually mountains are represented in
terms of the desert
so the way that the earth is often
represented in icons is
as a as a wilderness and as a desert
this has to do of course with kind of
like monastics and uh
and the the kind of
the kind of desertification that you
need to
to accomplish like this ascetic move
that you need to do
in order to receive the the the kind of
the holy
the divine light let's say so that's
what that's the way that i understand it
that's why the the mountains are cracked
you know often there are caves that's
the way that i see it
all right so rebecca asked hi jonathan
i'm really interested in the revolution
trope that you have outlined in a few of
your videos
the establishment of an order that is in
its turn continually renewed and
conquered
it is easy to see how this has
manifested itself in the sexual
revolution communist revolution
etc but is this narrative relevant to
the protestant reformation
where rebecca wants to get me in trouble
is what's going on here is this
why we now have so many christian
denominations that have splintered out
in the last 500 years
and so uh yes i do believe
i do believe that um
that the protestant reformation plays in
the revolutionary pattern
and uh and i do think that the
fragmentation
the the increasing fragmentation of the
protestant
churches is a sign of this revolutionary
pattern where churches are constantly in
danger of someone
rising up and making a new branch
um and i think that this is something
i've kind of hinted at before
where i've said that i
actually can follow martin luther to us
to a great extent in if you look at his
story
and his anger towards the corruption and
uh
and the kind of the the superficial
nature of some of the practices that
were in the church and
you know the um the abuse of the um
with the with the with the name of the i
forget the name of of of
of it anyways the the uh the the abuse
of the of the
of the system this like penitentiary
system
what's the name of it man it's so bad
sorry um
indulgences thank you susan martin that
was very good the abuse of the
indulgence system
i can i can follow him i i sympathize
with him but then
as soon as uh luther
names priests and this is actually you
might people think this is like a
technical thing like this is like a
like a technical thing but it's not
technical it is very much
the moment because luther was a monk
luther was
a laymonk he wasn't in the church
hierarchy
he did not have authority given to him
from someone else
this is the thing that's important this
is about pride this is the problem of
pride
is that authority has to be given to you
for you to act with authority in the
world authority has to be received
from someone else um now it is possible
for a prophet to appear
without authority coming from from the
hierarchy and you see that in scripture
all the time
a prophet rises up right the judges just
rise up and then start to act
but the prophets the judges
are not the priests and there's a
difference that is
luther the way it should have gone is
that like other saints in the church
like say max was the confessor or other
saints in the church who were persecuted
by their own church
saint john chrysostom was was was killed
by the
the the king the the the hierarchy of
the kings
but you shouldn't be taking the
authority that you don't have on
yourself and so
saying saint um and so luther should
have
should have criticized the church
criticized the church
you know and not necessarily look for
martyrdom but it's the moment where he
decides that all of a sudden he has the
authority to create a new church
and to name the name priest it's like i
don't know where that authority comes
from
i don't see it comes from himself or it
comes from a prince
but that doesn't make any sense and so
at that point
i pull out from like i can't i can't
follow luther anymore when that happens
now
despite that i believe that
i believe that the reformation is
playing a vital role
in how the whole pattern is playing out
that is
as as the church let's say
as the church moved away from quality
let's say
and in with through scandal like i'm not
justifying the scandals but
through scandal as it moved out of of
the higher aspect of christianity
it acquired a lot of a lot of
possibilities
and so there's a reason why the western
church evangelizes the entire world
for good or for ill in terms of politics
but that's what happened and so
there's a reason why the protestant
churches is like actually in its
fragmentation
kind of infiltrates every little aspect
of reality and like
finds itself in all these little corners
of all in in the world and
all these weird little protestant
churches kind of find themselves
everywhere
um and i think that despite everything i
think it
that is actually part of this kind of
filling up of the world
um like i said i'm not justifying the
reformation but i think
that it's part of the story and it's
actually going to surprise us
in the end uh there's going to be a
surprise where things are going to
actually kind of come together i don't
know how
and and i don't i'm not advocating some
kind of uh
ecumenical delusion but i think that in
the eschaton will
have a surprise that's all i can say
that's all i can say
all right so i need to take less time on
each question or else
um so kingsley asks can you speak to the
pattern that exists where the higher a
woman's intelligence
the less likely she is to marry do you
see any solutions to this problem
man you guys really want want me to get
into trouble um
all right kingsley
i mean i think that this has something
to do with
the role of masculine and feminine and
and i think that
you know jordan peterson has pointed
this out which is just a which is
something which is kind of inevitable
and is a is a pattern is that it's
it's it's much more it's more far more
difficult for
a woman to kind of give herself to
someone
she considers her inferior
in terms of in terms of intellect in
terms of
even in terms of uh amounts of
possessions
all these things it's it's difficult for
that to happen
uh whereas it's not so difficult from
the through the other way around
and so you know
what do i think would happen to those
women in like an ancient world
they would probably become actually
amazing people
they would just not marry and so there
is definitely a trade-off but i
i think that that probably people like
these amazing abbesses that you see in
the middle ages or
these saints that are just beyond
anything you know
the the great the great saints in the
church i think
that's possible that that's what was
going on is that the only person they
could give themselves
to was to christ and so it's like ah
like i'm sorry you know
um so i don't know but i don't think
like this is like a universal rule that
always happens
there are exceptions all the time this
is just like a general pattern
you know um so
so yeah so so someone in the in the
someone in the chat says that my wife's
smarter than me and we still got married
more
to marriage than just smart people are
yeah of course so that's that's
definitely true and so i don't want to
reduce all the marriage to that but it
is
a pattern that people have noticed and i
think that it it kind of has to do with
kind of has to do with the natural roles
of of
masculine and feminine and in the bible
but also just in
in reality so luca azkovic
asks the question is about the good
or neutral dragons
what role do they play symbolically not
from a modern perspective but
traditional where can we place them
in balkan folk belief and fairy tales
some dragons are helpless or men
and protectors of farmsteads and they
help fight off evil dragons yeah
the baseli head of steel fairy tale
they help resurrect the hero with the
water from the jordan river and
ultimately help him defeat the villain
another story a dragon king gives the
hero a gift
of unspoken language and with it he
could understand animals plants and
rocks
half dragons were thought of as great
winged heroes of men
so i mean i think you have to understand
it like gargoyles like that's the best
way you can understand
dragons or neutral dragons you know it's
like
on the edge of the church you have these
or saint christopher right i've talked
about
christopher quite a few times on the
edge of the church you have
you have monsters and those monsters
end up being able to defend you from
bigger monsters
and so i think that that's probably
that's probably the best way to
understand it
and so you could understand it you could
understand it um
like uh you could you could understand
it more
subtly let's say and think of how
the to think of how
the the the the rome let's say the the
emperor and constantinople
would hire a guard of viringians to
defend himself from
other nord northmen and so
he he hired these pagans right so you
can imagine these dragons these
these strangers that he hired them to
become his guard
and so he could turn them against
things that were of similar nature than
the
then the viringians which were the other
northmen who were
you know which who were very difficult
to stop or you could turn them against
the mongols or we could turn them
against
other groups that were more that were
kind of
difficult to manage and so that could be
a way to understand the idea of a
neutral dragon or a dragon that can be
turned as a defender like a gargoyle on
a church
all right so hopefully that makes sense
to you
so from mikao by the fruits you shall
know them
it seems to me that your public speaking
reveals itself to focus more attention
than your icon carving do you see the
symbolic world following a pattern to
manifest itself as big
as something like an orthodox bishop
virgin a bishop baron's word on fire
or the prager you look i just i
am just doing things one one at a time
that's how i'm approaching it you know
it's like i
i am just being grateful for whatever
opportunity
appears and trying to fill it as much as
i can
without you know to put as much energy
as i can
reasonably into the things that i see
and so
could that happen for sure i i do
believe that
that the symbolic world is participating
in something that's happening
maybe you say it that way i do think
that there's something happening
there's like there's like a movement i
don't know how else to say it
and i do think that this symbolic world
the symbolic world
not just not just me the way i'm doing
it but let's say as a
as a kind of change in the way people
think which encompasses a lot of other
things as well
i think that that's the the future
and uh i had a i had an interesting
conversation
last week you know a priest that i
really respect he asked me
uh he he said he was doing these zoom
calls with a with a catechumen and so i
said i asked him
if i could kind of jump in and talk to
the catechumens
and so it was really wonderful it was
wonderful for me because it was nice to
see catechumens
and uh one of the one of the the guys
i hope you won't be offended that i'm
using him as an example but one of the
guys
was saying that he was doubting like his
intentions to a certain extent
for being a catechumen because he said i
feel like i'm in some kind of like
secret club
and i feel like i'm part of the people
who knows what's going
on and you know like i'm i'm
there right i mean i'm where it's
happening and uh and he said because of
that he was actually wondering whether
or not he was
entering the church with the right
intentions which is which was actually
to me was quite beautiful in terms of
his
in terms of his uh in terms of his
intentions
um but it can show you that there i
think there's a lot of people that are
feeling that that it's like this is
there's something going on like there's
some kind of social change happening
and and i think and i do believe that
the symbolic world or
all of which is around it is uh is
participating in that so
we'll just take you know we'll take what
we can but i don't think i'm gonna stop
i'm gonna stop carving icons um one of
the things that's been amazing is that
with like your people support
on patreon and um
the different supports that i'm getting
i'm able like i've hired someone
part-time for the work on the videos to
kind of help me
uh do the advertisement and do all that
stuff that's been really wonderful she's
been awesome and i've also hired an
assistant for carving
and so through that i feel like i'm able
to then kind of accomplish more
um and so like like the support that
people have been giving me
has been really helpful to try to help
me
kind of just have more body right to
have more
possibilities to to move forward the
thing that's killing me though is the is
the email
like i need to find a solution to the to
the communication because
sometimes like i it's like it takes up
it takes up
a whole day and i'm like what did i do
today i just read emails and
and and answered some and didn't answer
others anyways
so uh but i think i will continue to
carve i don't see that stopping
okay so gardner brothers with the advent
of coveted lockdowns and remote work
is the west moving towards a new
gnosticism a separation of body
and mind body physical interactions that
mind soul working
and attention going towards online
endeavors with no physical basis
what's the christian way forward and i
yes i do believe that's true i do
believe that
that there is a kind of in incepted uh
gnosticism which is there
and the online idea and the kind of
transhuman
idea is also participating in this kind
of weird narcissism
like anybody who talks about the idea of
uploading your your
being to a computer is it is definitely
a gnostic
um or kind of weird modern version of
narcissism
um and uh and i see it as a danger like
even myself i see it as a danger i'm i'm
trying
so i think that the thing to do is to be
in is to kind of have the benedict
option
kind of strategy that uh rodriguez talks
about which is to
to to be deliberate about being involved
in your
local community and so i've been really
working towards
finding more space to kind of be
involved in my
local parish and a few of the local
parishes here and to see how even the
things i'm doing on the symbolic world
how they can be helpful to kind of
foster
let's say orthodoxy in quebec and and
kind of help
that in a more grounded way and so
i think that those are the kind of
things you have to do and i mean
obviously if you have a family and you
have kids
it helps because you know you're
constantly reminded of this world
because you
you're you have interactions with people
i would say just don't stop having real
interactions real loving interactions
with people around you
all right nelson justin evan says i feel
unev uneasy when i hear people refer to
their dogs as their children
it seems that the identity of a human
child is being improperly attributed to
an animal
there is an attempt to elevate the
animal to the level of the human yes
is a dog treated like a like a child a
chimera
scientists creating commemorative
genetic genetics can chimeras
also be made through improper identity
and acts of perception
um it has to do with one of it has to do
with equality this is one of the
problems of
of the idea of equality is that the idea
of equality kind of infects
the mind and then it starts to uh
to manifest itself in very strange ways
and so you know plato saw this in the
symposium
where socrates i think it's socrates i
think it's socrates who describes
democracy and he talks about how the the
problem with with democracy and the idea
of equality
one of the fruits of that is is that
people will
see start to see their animals treat
their animals as equal
and you could imagine that like veganism
has something to do with that too
it's like a weird idea that people see
themselves kind of at the same level as
everything as
as everything like everything is just
kind of flat um and so i agree and i
think it's also
it's also the fruit of people not having
kids and most people who
who treat their their animals as
children
uh either don't have kids or
or sometimes because animals a dog
especially
is absolutely most dogs are like
more affectionate and more subservient
than humans
and so it's a dangerous thing if you try
to
put all your kind of affection um and
authority into an animal because it
actually will work the dog
will you know will be completely
dependent on you and and so it can be a
temptation for those who
who don't have children or who
maybe don't not wouldn't say don't like
their children or i would say maybe
aren't aren't willing to put in the
effort needed to really connect
with your children so um but i don't
have a problem with having a pet i have
a cat i like my
cat i pet my cat you know it's it's fine
um
you know and i and i don't want a dog
but it's also because of the trouble but
i
have no problem with people have dogs
and and connect with dogs as well i
would just say
it's it's mostly when people go all all
out and
you know you i mean people know the
difference like you know people who
treat their pets
as if they're human and if as if their
pets or their or their children
so hopefully i'm not offended all you
guys with the dogs
all right so blank says hi jonathan what
is this symbolism of smoke
specifically smoking tobacco
you know i've always wondered if if if
there's something of smoking which has
to do with burning incense
like i've really i really wondered if
that's not part of its appeal
if there's something really kind of
primordial
about watching smoke rise up from your
own
mouth that it's a kind of something that
is so
intuitively right that
it will that you know that that people
are
attracted to it you know i've always
wondered about that
but that's usually in terms of smoke
like in terms of uh burning incest for
example it really does have to do with
this rising up
of of of at least rising up of
intention up to the heaven let's say so
it's like an offering up it goes up to
the sky
and it's it's like a subtle offering
because it
you can imagine that you have something
physical
and then as you consume it it becomes
subtle
and then it rises up right and so you
can understand that
as stupid as right like i eat a sandwich
and because i eat the sandwich then i
can concentrate during the day
right and so you take a physical thing
you consume it
somehow you burn it you eat it you know
you you consume it and then it becomes
more subtle and participates in
intelligence you could say
and so i think that that's what um for
humans that i think that's what smoke
has often meant in terms of
especially the kind of smoke that goes
up the kind of offering of incense and
all that
um
all right so jeff young so jeff you have
a really long question i'm gonna skip
to the question part
so you basically talk about the idea of
food
like what is what is food and then you
ask me what is
eating so have you written or spoken
about this before or know of any other
resources
you can point me to so yes i did write
uh
i did write a um i didn't make a video i
think it's called food sex and communion
and i go directly into the symbolism
of food so it's quite simple like it's
food
is is uh in terms of
being food is potentiality and so
you you gather it you know you you break
down
the identities of the food into
potentiality and then you
bring them to you and you make them
participate in
your being and so they become potential
for you
um and so in one of the videos too with
my brother on symbolism i forget which
one i did too
he talks about how like we are food for
cities let's say
so human beings are the food of cities
and this the city
gives intelligence down back to the
people who are being eaten
by the city and so it's it's like that
it's like you you take
matter you put it into you and then you
impose intelligence on it you impose
pattern on it
and so that is really the best way to
kind of understand uh eating
in the basic sense but then there's also
another type of eating which is
which is actually the idea of the food
from heaven and the food from heaven is
different
you see the see that in in uh in
scripture
food from heaven is more like seed and
so it's actually getting
pattern and that seems to be more
what communion does communion actually
does
does both at the same time sorry
community always does everything
um but let's say in scripture the idea
of like mana for example this like food
that
comes down from heaven and condenses and
is like a
kind of getting of seed or getting a
pattern
um and so that's a little different from
the the the basic
symbolism of eating
all right so so josh the mover says the
orthodox mind seems to have sympathy for
protestantism and so far as prosecution
was protesting the sins of the roman
land church and condemning for them
and condemning and condemnation for them
for not returning to the orthodox church
um it seems that the very spirit of
america echoes the protestant movement
and those fundamental motivations as a
christian given the responsibility to be
patriotic and loyal to one's nation
i don't want to fall into the pessimism
of those who endemically
univocally call america the new babylon
is there any hope for america our
current spiral seems to look a lot like
what led up to russia's revolution
but at least they had an orthodox memory
which america has never had
can christianity still resurrect in a
land that hasn't properly imitated
christ
so the answer is yes the christianity
can resurrect in a land that hasn't
properly imitated christ just like
christianity rose
in rome or in armenia or in all these
places where it rose
and so i would say to be very careful
to be very careful that
like orthodox the orthodox who who want
to rebel
against the american leadership
because american leadership is not
orthodox this is a
this is to me is is a they're being
extremely protestant when they
do that it's like you're called to
submit to your authorities
you know insofar as they don't ask you
to do something
which is contradictory due to the
teaching of christ
and that's it you know the christians
were in rome
and were worshipping and who were not
worshipping they weren't worshiping
who were obeying nero who was the worst
most decadent disgusting emperor that
ever existed and who
persecuted them but they would still not
feel like
it was their role to to break uh to
break the rules or to kind of uh to be
these kind of political dissidents and
so that's what i think
i don't um not a big fan
of but i mean i also think that america
is the new babylon
but i still think that you need to obey
your authority so
just like the christians obeyed the
authority in rome
at the time when rome was the babylon so
okay all right so we are done with the
symbolic world
so let's go into
patreon
okay so neil degrade
emmanuel the great are you there in the
in the chat i think he's probably not
there in the chat because
neil uh this is neil is the the the
singer from uh dirt poor robbins
and he's actually working on a really
great little movie that he's working on
and and i had the chance to kind of
participate in some of the development
of the screenplay obviously was it was
his idea
but he kind of asked me some ideas about
symbols and everything and it's going to
be really good i'm really excited to see
it
come out so neil asks i think i speak
and they're also becoming by the way
drupal robbins i think has become the
official
uh band of the symbolic world their last
single is called
uh anthem to the ends of the world which
is just it's a great song
just as a song it's great but some of
the words in there are just
are just like i wish i could have
phrased things that way let's just say
it that way
um so neil says i think i speak for
everyone when i ask
what the heck happened to the bow tie
this is the bow tie that that i wore in
saskatoon i still have the bow tie
and uh uh my my son is
actually probably gonna go back to
saskatoon i promised myself
that i would wear the bow tie when i
went back to saskatoon
but because of cobit i haven't gone back
but my son might actually be going there
for the summer
to kind of work and participate in the
great community that's there
and so he said that he is going to uh
he's going to wear the bow tie so
that'd be cool all right
um okay so
charlie longoria asks how can i explain
what an
angle is to someone who is technically
minded
my fiance is atheistic agnostic and i'm
about to be christmated in the orthodox
church next month
i i'm sorry i don't understand she came
with me a couple services and she's
noticing that orthodoxy very different
from other
forms of christianity and started asking
what an angle was in the orthodox church
oh okay i was like you mean angel
i i was like angle angle what an angle
like especially because you said
how do you how do you explain an angle
to someone who's technically minded
i was like actually it's probably pretty
simple to explain it to somebody who's
technically minded because an angle is
pretty technical
uh okay and so he says i tried to
explain it to her showing her pics
of seraphim and sheriff him but i think
i ended up sounding mentally ill
all right so how do you explain an angel
to someone who's technically minded
is that you explain it as the division
of labor
if you want to go that way so you the
military is the best way to explain an
angel
which is that let's say the general
gives an order
but that order has implications that
have to be
worked out and so those implications get
worked out at different levels
of a hierarchy by beings who then become
the heads of other levels
and so so the best way to understand
angels is to understand how how moses
set up the um the leadership of israel
with like
heads of heads of thousands heads of
hundreds heads of
tens and so that's what angels are is
that they are
they are the distribution of the will of
god
into a hierarchy of being through beings
down
all the way to you and so
the idea is that the way that people
have talked about the world before
which is that it's like god and then
flat material mechanical existence
that's just not the way that christians
have ever understood reality that's not
how
any religion anybody has ever understood
reality
until very recently and so we understand
reality as
a as a procession a hierarchy of beings
that process
from the infinite down into the
particular and
above us are angels and they become
messengers because they carry the
message of god
down to my specific reality my specific
context and they also have
specific functions let's say in the
reigning over the cosmos in the way that
the world
works um and uh and so
that's the only way to to explain it and
and i think that some people will really
resist to that especially people that
have been used to this idea of like
god and then everything else below um
but that's really how reality works and
like i said that's how
all organizations end up working like
an organization that has just a leader
and then everybody flat at the bottom
that organization
will not work there's no way that that
will work properly
for an organizations to work you need to
have like a president
and then vice presidents and then chiefs
of departments
and uh and so forth and so forth down to
the nitty gritty of the organization
and that's also how the world actually
works not just
our organizations but the organization
of the cosmos works that way
as well okay
okay so garrett witner
garrett whitner asked what is the
symbolism of the vinegar people are
continually offering christ on the cross
is this just meant as further insult or
is there a deeper meaning
or cultural cue i'm missing maybe i just
don't like vinegar but i interpret it as
offering an intentionally worse version
of his gift back to him you gave us
grapes we made wine
and let it go bad here you go
um
so the so the way to to understand it
there the thing is that
it's for it's hard to talk about the
crucifixion because it it actually um
i always it contains so much that it's
difficult to
to to completely full fill that but
let's say a way to to um
to understand the vinegar has to do with
the idea of
of the end has to do the idea of
reaching the end
and so the notion is so you know how
uh it's you drink uh
beer and at the end of the beer there
are the dregs you know you drink
wine at the at the bottom you know
there's there's the
the bitterness is at the bottom and so
and so vinegar
has to do with uh bitterness like this
idea of something which is actually not
palatable and so it's a tasting of death
is what
ultimately i think it means it means
that he's ready to die
and so uh and so like so you can
understand they offer him vinegar
in some gospels and he doesn't take it
and then after that they do and then he
dies and so there's something about that
it has to do with it a way to understand
it would be like uh
drinking seawater is something it would
be another way that it could have been
manifested let's say the idea of
the mara right the the bitter waters the
waters of chaos and so that's what he's
drinking he's
he's he's drinking the waters of chaos
you could say um
and so there's a there's an irony of
course like everything that happens in
the
in the on the cross is that you could
say
that he is drinking the bitter waters
and so he's dying but you could also say
that he's drinking the bitter waters and
he's actually going to contain them
and so he's actually so drinking the
water the drinking the vinegar
as the logos is akin to
filling up death with himself right it's
like he's actually taking death into
himself
and he's containing it uh and so that's
also kind of
like the kind of irony that's happening
on on the cross in terms of this idea of
the bitterness of the end
um so yeah
okay so
so uh bjorn olson has a long question
says that he can i can skip to the
second part so i will do that burn sorry
i can understand what you mean when you
talk about the world existing through
order
attention or even hierarchy but would it
truly cease to exist if there were no
one
who has manifested the logos to their
full capacity or do you mean that there
would be some kind of
downward domino effect where in the
event of the saints disappearing
no one would ever be able to reach that
level in the hierarchy of the church
again
and that matter making the body of
christ disappear
one upper level science bishop priest at
a time
i'm not sure i totally understand so can
you please elaborate on this notion i
can't make any sense out of it
and by the way please bring your
conversation and interviews to spotify
yes
that is happening actually um and so
and so the person working with me has
found i need to do that like
there's something i need to do and it's
gonna it's gonna work um
so that will be happening very soon
um so so the thing is one of the
problems with these kinds of questions
is that speculative questions have no
value this is this is like i see this
all the time like i see it like people
get caught up
by atheists in these kinds of questions
where they're like
what if there was a world you know where
the birds were intelligent and the the
humans were
stupid now then they asked some moral
question
based on this speculative imaginary
world
and so it's like the world you describe
where it says where no one has
manifested the logos to their full
capacity
that's not going to happen until if it
happens it's the end of the world it's
like that's not
the world the world that's that doesn't
so what you could so you could
understand it that yes you could
understand the idea that as
the saints diminish then the light
diminishes
and as the saints as there are less
saints
then at some point the world becomes
prone to destruction
and so an image of that of course the
ultimate image is in the story of sodom
and gomorrah where
it feels like the world is so completely
corrupt
that i mean it's in the time of noah as
well so i feel like the world is so
completely corrupt
that um it's going to fall apart it's
going to break apart there will be
no nothing is holding it together um
and the way that it's going to manifest
itself is all kinds of
in all kinds of ways like people will
rip each other to shreds then the
the the let's say the infrastructure
will
will break down so think about it this
way so if nobody's manifesting the logos
at least to a certain capacity then
what's the reason to uphold all these
things these dykes these electrical
systems all of these things
need truth need uh people who are honest
and straightforward to
hold them so if nobody is manifesting
logos at all
then the world is gonna eat us you know
it's gonna eat us by
breaking apart by the house falling down
by it's gonna actually
it's actually going to fall apart like
it's it's
so that's the best way i can maybe
explain that i hope that that makes
sense
all right so keenan wang asks how does
the idea of sins of the left hand and
the right hand relate to the idea
that each of us has an angel of the
right hand and an angel of the left hand
smart guy canaan in particular what is
the purpose of the angel
of the left hand does the angel of the
right hand remind us that we are one
with god while the angel of the left
hand reminds us that we're human and
separate from god
uh which seems to be both a warning and
statement of our purpose as part of
creation so the angel on the left hand
is a demon
like it's a it's they're definitely like
angels and demons are the same
type of being but it's important to kind
of distinguish them
and so the way that the way that uh
father stephen talked about this in
terms of uh saying gregory
um i think of sangri the great
who who who talks about the angels of
the left hand in job
and so the idea is something like
the the demon let's say is
is helping you despite itself and so
it's it's uh so you can understand it
like this
so you could understand it like
the temptations you have they
are reminding you of something and so
they the the the temptations and the
accusations they can drag you away
but they can also if you're attentive
they can also be the sign to kind of
turn to turn the other way as well to
turn
the right side towards towards the
divine let's say
um so you know how how
also this idea that so like i mean i
don't know if you felt like
maybe i'm the only one who felt it like
if you give in to your passion like you
consummate some sin some excess some
something then when that happens there's
like a weird moment
after that and there's like a weird
moment that you can grab onto
and that can actually help you to
to uh to get better you know it's like
you can call it regret you can call it a
kind of sobering you can call it a
a a kind of little moment of of uh
being awake you know after whatever it
is you you've done or what
you know you you you lie for example you
know you you're talking to someone
and you lie for no good reason to just
make yourself look good or to
to avoid a problem or whatever and so
it's like you lie
and then all of a sudden it like hits
you you you realize that you've lied
and that little moment like that can
actually be like a moment of salvation
if you grab it if you catch it and you
hold on to it it can
it can it can be of great use to you
um and so i think in that sense that's
what the the demon on the
on the left hand how it's participating
in your salvation
and so i'm not saying that you should
sin like i'm not saying you should sin
i'm not saying it's good to send like
please don't
think that's what i'm saying but i'm
saying there's something about
falling and this little moment of like
wake up that you get when you
give into something and uh
then that can yeah that's that can be a
really good good moment yeah
all right
so wall walrus king 14 says our church
tradition teaches us that both the
rabbis of judea
and the church fathers believe that the
seven archangels of heaven are each
charged with protecting
one of the known celestial bodies the
son
through saturn do you have any good
christian sources on which archangel
is charged with which body
all i can find is confirmation that the
church fathers did indeed believe this
the only attempts to compare celestial
bodies to archangels
that i find are in laughably bad i
called his blog spot folks
i've never i i've never thought about
that like i've heard
that analogy but i've never thought
about
uh identifying the uh the angels
um and so i would be very careful but if
you do find
like a credible source for that you
should send it my way because i'd be
interested in seeing
if uh if there's something you can map
onto
the celestial bodies in terms of their
kind of traditional meaning
celestial spheres let's say in terms of
their usual
their kind of traditional meaning that'd
be really interesting but i'm afraid i
do not know
i've never heard that before
um so merkel says spiders as a symbol in
mythic narrative what do you think about
symbolism in dreams so
i mean spiders can have several several
um aspects in mythic narratives but i
think that
mostly a good way it's the negative
aspect of the spider let's say it's
usually it's a lot it seems like more
prominent in western
tales at least and it usually has to do
with something like uh
like the like the dangerous feminine
right and so
the the the spider builds a web
that actually makes like a home um
for itself and it's actually like a it's
actually like a
a traditional structure it has a
hierarchy like it's made like a wheel
let's say
uh but this home is like a trick
and once you once you kind of enter to
the home
then you realize that you are kind of
trapped and you get eaten
so so i think that that's really like
the negative aspect of the
of the spider um and so what about
symbolism and dreams i mean
i i think i've said this often before i
think
symbolism and dreams is definitely
possible and i think that it's
that it can that it can be helpful but
most of the time it's not and
it's most of the time kind of just like
a a kind of
fallen a kind of gibberish nonsense um
so
i would just be careful not to be too
attentive to that
um but if you do get an insight about a
dream
then i think that it can it can be
helpful once in a while but
i i don't you know the church fathers
really warn against dreams
even though they do believe that you can
have a vision and dream every they
believe that but they
they warned that it's dangerous to pay
too much attention to that so
um
all right so dorothea
asks a question
uh it says the book of sirach says that
a man's wickedness is better than a
woman's goodness
is there any way to explain this further
without getting into trouble so why
so someone actually wrote an answer and
says let's see what they say
so romeo says forgive my response just
putting things in perspective
this is the full verse from wisdom of
sirach do not
look upon anyone for beauty and do not
sit in the midst of women
for a moth comes out of garments and the
evil of a woman comes from a woman
the evil of a man is better than a woman
who does
what is good yet brings shame and
disgrace
for a moth comes out of garments and the
evil of a woman comes from a woman the
evil of a man
is better than a woman who does what is
good
yet brings shame and disgrace
i would definitely have to think about
that because i don't think i completely
understand
um
i have to think about that i never
thought about it it's kind of weird it's
a very strange statement
it shows you that i don't read the
apocryphal books enough
i probably should read them more because
i i don't i don't think i've ever even
seen that verse or i'd know about it
um
okay so julius barztitis
asks my question is about whether the
concession of god has perfect stands in
opposition to dynamism in other words
does
perfection imply pure stasis as if
not and i'm soon not then how should one
try to think about a non-static yet
perfect being
how does one while saying yes to
immutability and changelessness still
incorporate the liviness of god as
complementary
and not opposed to his perfection
and so i think that the way to
understand it is kind of like the way
that you understand
uh the understand divinity
understand the trinity which is
it's an aporia i don't know what to tell
you it's it's like
in the world there is both identity and
change or identity
unity and multiplicity or our identity
and
dynamism let's say and so
the way that christians seem to want to
deal with that is to
is to basically put them up all the way
into god
in an infinite manner in a way that is
not completely resolved
in language it's not completely resolved
in in in
thinking and in logos like in in logic
let's say
and so so it doesn't like there
definitely is
a sense of dynamism in the trinity
but there's also a a sense of perfect
you know unity let's say in god and
stasis in the sense of you know
this passion right in the sense that god
is not subject
to anything but his that his own
inner life uh let's say and so
but they're definitely like in terms of
of orthodox christianity there isn't the
sense that god is
is static and and the idea that it's all
this like
this idea of the like uh the monad or
the you know the one
only kind of contemplating himself in
perfect stasis
that's not that's not the vision of um
of uh orthodoxy and it's also it's a
problem
because when you conceive of god that
way
it inevitably at some point leads to the
to the problem of seeing the world as
somehow
a kind of broken shell or a mistake or
that creation itself
is is somehow a kind of fallen thing
or a byproduct or something um
so why lawrence ask why is faith
associated with salvation
so because because salvation first of
all happens through
trust and so trust is what makes you
move you could say you need trust in
order
to be bound to something and so
in order for salvation in order for you
to be healed or to be transformed
you need to you need to trust
because trust is actually the thing that
unites
multiplicity together i mean you could
say love but
faith is another way to kind of
understand it uh
that seems to have more to do with
intelligence let's say
and so so it's like
so you could see it you could see it you
could see it as a you could see it as a
as a doctor right
even even in terms of what's happening
now with kovid and so
a lot of people let's say who have a
problem with what's going on or have a
pro
or are doubtful about the vaccine or
doubtful about um what's happening
it's not about it's not about uh
it's about trust it's it's not about
like
thinking that medicine works or not or
that vaccine works or not it's about
it's about trusting those that have
power and authority
and they're giving myself to them and so
if you want to
be healed then you have to trust christ
like
you're not going to follow christ you're
not going to try to be like him if you
don't trust him
you have to first trust and then that
out of that trust the fruits
of of that trust are going to manifest
themselves
but if you if you like if you try to
follow a bunch of rules without trusting
the goal
or trusting the image that you're that
you're imitating
then it's not going to give you anything
you actually have to
trust that's how reality that's one of
the ways reality holds together
so i hope this makes sense
uh so blake payne says hi my name is
cuthbert i'm using my parents patreon to
post well
thankful to your parents to uh to let
your uh to to let you post
i'm fascinated by the symbolism of yin
and yang is it accurate
i've heard a critique from a friend
saying it overemphasizes the need for
evil and the grand narrative
as a necessary and equal opposing force
that if good gets too strong evil must
rise to meet to keep a balance
she said it was manny chaostic
i can understand it in terms of the
balance of chaos and order are those
uniquely different classifications than
good and evil yes
i think you're totally right i think
that uh it's i think that seeing it as
good and evil
or simply as good and evil is definitely
a problem
the yin yang is uh the yin yang is
is it's just opposites and so it's like
heaven and earth
uh the idea that the world the motor of
the world is opposites you could say
but the the it's not a mani key it's not
a manichaean in several ways one is that
it shows that the motor of the one is
the other and so that's why there's a
dot in the black but there's a white dot
in the black part and there's a
black dot in the white part because it's
showing how
the the relationship of opposites
is actually a kind of co-mutual mutual
relationship
where one makes the other exist in this
kind of dynamic unity
and one of the things that people forget
is that
the the yin yang is is a circle it's in
a circle
so it's so you can understand it as just
pure duality but it's not pure duality
because
it's actually united together in a in a
circular shape
so the unity of the yin yang symbol
appears in its circular form
and then within that unity you see
the basic duality of heaven and earth
kind of play itself out and so
at least that's how i understand it and
and i don't i think the yin yang symbol
is great i don't have a problem with it
i think it's a quite
it's a quite powerful um it's a quite
powerful image and it's
it's actually surprisingly universal
they
i've seen i've actually seen uh versions
of it like
ancient they found these like ancient uh
these ancient
bowls that had ying yang symbols in
europe you know from like thousands and
thousands of years ago
so i think it's a i think it's a good
symbol you know i wouldn't
like i think it's good but it's not ours
in the sense that it's
you can think meditate you can think
about it but like i would be very wary
if someone
put a yin yang symbol in a church and
tried to justify that to me
i'd be like uh you know what that's not
a good idea let's not do that let's just
let's just follow our own tradition
follow our own kind of
it's not that it wasn't really it's not
a symbol that was given to us within
the christian tradition but it i think
it has a lot of insight to offer
nonetheless
um
so g garcia says uh i just wanted to
mention
psychopaths to increase the demand for
anime analysis
uh it's like the modern brave new world
but its own thing i will see that
if i ever make an analysis of an anime
it's going to be
attack on titan because it's the only
one that i'm watching but very slowly
let's say i think you know it's like i'm
watching like
two one episode a week or something like
two episodes a week so it's not
it's not going fast alright so jason
lindsay asks
hey jonathan what do you think is the
solution to the problem of hybridization
now that it seems like it's here to stay
is there any way to channel
hybridization into something good
or like in the old testament stories is
the real solution
to completely destroy the hybrid
monsters then stop mixing
as someone who has been obsessed and
fascinated with hybrids for most of his
life and has come to realize the
existential danger of their existence
and really seeking an answer to this
problem that does not result in
accelerating it so okay
so hybrids exist
like they they they uh they exist
they've always existed there are hybrids
um
in the sense of we have mules
you know mules are are hybrids
um and so there are always been
a kind of hybridity and so
and hybridity has a function like
the like the gargoyles have a function
they have a function
in a way like the cherub as a function
that is the hybrid
manifests the edge right manifest the
limit
so hybrids have a function saint
christopher
stands on the side of the river and
crosses people over that's what the
hybrid does it's like a
it's a it's a it can act as a as a
buffer
between two identities right so you know
it's not it's not it's not
you know it's like you have a you have a
country or you have a tribe
like say a country or an empire so you
have the roman empire you have the
persian empire
and in between somewhere where they
touch people are going to intermarry
and it's going to be they won't know
exactly which side they're on they're
going to be a mix of persian
and roman and that happens just
naturally to show the limit
right on the limit is our hybrids now
the problem
uh with what's going on now
is two things one is
the fascination with hybrids
that is the wanting to make hybrids the
central
thing we're attentive to so hybridity
has become
the main narrative of the story and it
seemed it's
we people act as if it's not an accident
that happens due to identities and so
you can
so hybridization is something which
happens naturally when two identities
encounter each other
somehow but they see it as a value in
itself
and almost like as a virtue
and this is like weird and you see it
like you pay attention you'll see it
like there
people act as if hybridization is a
virtue
and this is not this is the problem
that's one
the second is the desire to make human
hybrids the desire to hybridize
the human and so what does that mean
that means bringing the hybrid into the
intelligent space
it's like it's like it really is then
become the ultimate symbol of the
of the end because it's like it's like
uh it's the the the uh
the abomination in the in the holy of
holies right it's bringing the
abomination
into the highest place and so trying to
make
human hybrids is the ultimate tool for
the destruction of
our world like it's if that starts to
really manifest itself
it's gonna be it's it's like you're
gonna count the days people it's going
to
be
it's going to be that's it you know
all right so anjo terpstra
says hey jonathan i got a question on
your video on the symbolism conspiracy
theory
you state that as christianity falls
away infanticide and suicide
of the elderly will appear you may be
going to this and how it is related to
pagan culture
um
and so i mean ancient cultures
in different ways so so different
practices like the romans practiced
infanticide
the uh the the scandinavians tend to
practice a kind of uh elderly suicide or
or a way to get rid of your elderly
um
and and and the christianity sees in
each person
a manifestation of the logos and sees
also it's it's like this is why i say
it's like kind of like the proper
hierarchy
so it's in in its proper hierarchy it
tends
to want to recognize even in the
smallest thing
the seed of the logos and so that's why
christ says
things like you know if you help the
littlest of these
then i you're helping me because it's
harder
it's harder for most people to see let's
say god or the will of god
in that which is lower that which is
which is not in the prime of life let's
say in the prime of energy
and and paganism like i would say a lot
of the paganisms
they they worship the prime primal
energy
you know it's it's and you see it
even in the neo pagans right they have
this they have a they have the kind of
worship
strength and this the
kind of vivaciousness and this kind of
this kind of uh spirit of of of youth
and of
you know of energy but that's
that that it has a problem because
you're gonna die
like you're gonna get old everybody does
uh and so you have to actually be able
to deal with that with the
you have to be able to deal with that in
a normal way and so
christianity has the idea of caring for
the weak
and caring for those that are
recognizing that they're weak it's not
like you're going to make an infant
it's not like you're like you understand
that the elderly are weak
and that they're approaching death but
there is a way in which there is a care
for them um and so but as christianity
falls away
it's just gonna happen it's already
happening i mean
infanticide i think that even even now
it's just abortion but i think that
infanticide is just around the corner
um and it's not going to be it's
it's not going to take a lot of time
because it before it becomes uh
if not officially accepted that at least
kind of uh
let's say tacitly accepted
and same thing for the elderly and so
we're gonna see we're going to see uh
a we're gonna see systems to make people
feel
like they they've lived their lives now
it's time to check out you know
and it's gonna happen more and more it's
already it's already there so
all right so hi jonathan i'm struggling
to see will and volition in the forms of
things that
aren't specifically related to
personhood
what is the will and volition of the
angel of the cup
all right i will humor you uh i would
say don't pay too much attention to the
angel of the cup it's probably not worth
your attention
but i mean the will of the angel of the
cup is that there that you have a good
cup
it's not any more than that it's not
about it's it's just
it's just that the the the principle
that is ruling
the cup is that it'd be a good cup
you know in the characteristics of the
of what a cup is
that's the that's about as good as i'm
gonna get for an answer
uh on that
all right so norm gone says i'm
wondering if you can explore the
connection between god instructing moses
to leave tassels on garments
to serve as a reminder to follow his
commands and the fringe as a necessary
remainder
or something unaccounted for uh in
what ways is the margin allied to
remembering rather than forgetting
and so you could understand that the the
fringe
is a reminder of the of the multiplicity
or the or
the fragmentation so when you see a
fringe on a vestment
it reminds you of your own fringe it
reminds you of your own
capacity to to kind of fall into that
breakdown and so in that sense it the
fringe acts as a frame
for the order and it acts as a remainder
that you reach the edge of the order and
so
it can be
the freak can can the freak will
will remind you of what is normal just
like the the fringe will remind you
of the knee of the importance of the
order of the vestment
and so because you won't you won't just
you won't take it for granted and so
to leave a fringe
uh can help you remember
order it can help you kind of understand
the reason
for order because you see what happens
when it's not
when it kind of starts to fall apart
um so jason gadawaltz asks
what is the symbolism of 11
i know like i don't think i i understand
that well enough
i know what you're asking and also
because of the the the
666 magic square has has
uh 11 6 times 11 but i don't think
people have tried to explain it to me
like mature would probably
understand this way more like he he
would probably have a much better
understanding of this and he could
probably tell you but
i'm afraid that i'm not going to be have
a good answer for that
for that sorry um
all right so steven bishop asks
um what does it mean that icons of
christ in gethsemane often depict him
without his outer garment
there seems to be a strong parallel
without between gethsemane and sinai as
christ goes further up the mountain
leading behind more and more disciples
just as moses does
and also the enoch mountain as christ
moves more clothing
and closer he gets to the cross
reversing the the garments of skin
etc um am i seeing this correctly
uh i think you're right i think that
that that
but i think that it's two things i think
that it is on the one hand
um
and it's funny because after that uh
steve asked and if so how does the color
symbolism of his garments play into it
blue being his divinity and red being
his humanity and iconographic color
theory so yeah so
see he's going to that that like uh he's
going to that um
that definition that i told you about
which is the idea of
blue as as uh as divinity and red as
humanity that we talked about with like
the blue red and red blue
uh with the virgin um i mean i i i kind
of get it i'm not
totally sure about that but uh okay so
let's say in terms of removing the
garment
i think that i think that it had to do
with crucifixion
it has to do with christ also accepting
his crucifixion so it makes sense that
he would
remove his garments in the sense of
going up the mountain to eden like you
said but i think
there's also something about trying to
call to its crucifixion
but it's funny that i've never even
noticed that i would have to look at
those icons because it's like
i never noticed that christ isn't
wearing his outer garment in that icon
so
if that's true you've like taught me
something really cool i need to
need to look into that
all right swords into plowshares asks
jonathan how does an understanding of
the meaning of facing
time in the fall alongside the meaning
of an
unprepared approach to knowledge of
opposites relate with the non-dualism of
the super cosmic
super cosmic absolute uh
facing time in the fall
well i mean
i'm not sure i totally understand your
question but if if i think i understand
it
there's a sense in which duality
is part of the world right not dualism
in the sense of
um of like this this like
inseparable like this these absolute
opposites let's say kind of like
manichaeism like we talked about before
but duality is the motor of
manifestation
that's why god creates heaven and earth
and creates these two basic categories
and then
then it's like a it's like uh
it's like a one and a zero right it's
the motor of reality it's like on off on
off on off that's how a motor works and
so reality
that's how reality works too it has like
a it has two modes
like two opposites and then within those
opposites then
then uh that's how reality manifests
itself and so
but the idea is that of course that is
not absolute like the absolute is beyond
those
opposites and is actually non-dual um
but
but duality is real it's not a it's not
an illusion the way that a lot of people
tend to think about i don't i don't
really dislike that um
and so and so you could say that the
saint um
said never from the syrian has a
wonderful image of that in the uh
in the hymns uh paradise where he says
that
if adam and eve had waited to receive
the fruit from god rather than take it
for themselves
then they would have seen sickness
as someone who is healthy but
because they took the fruit for
themselves then
they saw health as someone who is
sick right so it's like you could
understand that
if we had taken the fruit in the proper
manner
then duality becomes an expression
of of something above it
but when you fall into duality then you
get trapped
in these opposites and you get trapped
in this like
in a sense that inside outside you know
how
as soon as adam falls what does he do he
like blames eve right he just like it's
her
and so right away you see this like this
inside outside what does he do
he's afraid because he's naked he
realizes he sees
now the world outside of him as
dangerous
right away and so he's he's he's a slave
of
the of the duality he's already become a
slave of duality
because he sees the difference between
inside and outside as completely as an
absolute
state um and so that's the difference
that's that's the difference but i mean
i say that but it's like it's not like
i live in a non-dual continual non-dual
realization so
it's not like i i uh i completely
understand it we have glimpses of it you
know
um so doggy boy says i remember
somewhere you talk about the symbolism i
think a baptismal font
how heaven is and earth is represented
like a square base and a round top now
that that would not be a baptismal font
that would be
a church like a like a traditional
orthodox church
so it's evident that we're such a
fractured moment in time that we
especially talk about symbolism rather
than just living it
does this mean that in the designing of
objects of worship were doomed to copy
from specific periods
where the symbolic intuition was more or
less still intact
at least until we cultivate the more
felt sense of the somali world
were things more coherent in the past
and thus you can point to a chair and
say that's jacobian
whereas in the future no one would be
able to point anything
from this moment and identify us as such
i'm
i'm an apprentice furniture maker and
was wondering as an artist
if you have any advice or sources that
one can use to get a better
understanding of this stuff
ornamentation and symbolic design
elements etc
um
well i mean i think that i think that on
the on the first hand like the
difference between
the relationship between a church being
a
dome on a square let's say and the style
of a chair is is quite different and so
there there is in church architecture
for example
like in orthodox church architecture
it's like a basic pattern
and then and then within that basic
parent there's uh there's also
variability
and that variability is actually a
function of the world it's a function of
of multiplicity
existing within unity and so it doesn't
mean that every church has to be
a copy of every other church give me a
second i just want to open the door
i like made my office soundproof and now
sometimes i run out of air in my office
you can see in some videos if you watch
you'll see i like start to sweat here
and it's because the door is closed and
then it's been too long
and i'm like starting to run out of air
in my office all right sorry
what was i saying yes the difference
between a a
uh a basic structure which is like a
dome on a square
um and the style of a chair it's quite
different and so
a chair needs like you can see it this
way like a chair
has to have a a balance
for it to exist like it has to have four
legs and let's say a back
and arm rest like these are things that
a chair has
and depending what like obviously a more
formal chair will have armor that's a
less formal chair
will won't necessarily have armrests you
know there'll be elements which will
naturally be derived from what the
purpose of the chair is
like if it's supposed to be a camping
chair then obviously a lot of things
can go in terms of the formality of the
chair or the solidity
the stability all of this is going to
inform design
and so design is it should be purpose
driven
like if you want to make a chair that
will
be in a waiting room for a
for in a medical establishment and that
chair will be different from a chair you
make for
a dining table and even in terms of
dining tables
one chair will be a chair that's made
for like
the the table you eat around breakfast
like a little table
you know that's in the kitchen and your
actual table where you receive people
let's say in your dining room
all of this is what's going to inform
the design and so design should always
be purpose
oriented and then
then you do have something like
ornamentation
but ornamentation
has to also has to be kind of like the
glory of the chair or the glory that is
added to the object and usually that
glory will be related to something else
but that's something else which is which
makes sense to you in the sense that
that's why let's say certain tribes
certain cultures will develop certain
ornamentations it's not a static thing
it's a
it's something that changes but you'll
still be able to recognize
let's say the difference between uh
let's say tour egg ornamentation
and like let's say british ornamentation
and in the baroque period
um and so and so you just have to there
just has to be like a balance
and if you understand what ornament is
then you will also understand
its role and you'll you'll be able to
place it properly
so if you have a chair that's too
ornament like let's say you make a super
ornamented chair with like
frills and gold and all of this right
and then you
you uh you put it in a in a
like a like a barber shop it's gonna
stay
it's gonna be a freak thing it's gonna
stand out so you have to
things have to meet there there so if
you make a very ornamented chair you
wanted them to be
in a very formal setting and maybe a
special chair in a formal setting
so that's kind of the that's how i see
it um
i don't that makes sense i hope that
makes sense
all right okay so
uh romeo says i want to know the
symbolism of one-sided love
why would god permit this and is there a
role
is there a role the one i love ought to
play
saving the girl saving myself giving up
everything divine intervention
sometimes i feel like i'm in a romance
movie maybe forrest gump something about
mary oh my goodness
this is this my thorn man i'm sorry
uh i was a coward and used to escape
from my feelings and
understandably no one fell into my lap
but since god came into my life he
transformed me
and i now feel courageous with
expressing my feelings and have
but with no difference so it seems from
my perspective
can symbolic understanding help me see
possible paths
am i a type of fool okay
so romeo
dude you you use the word use the name
romeo you're gonna ask a
serious question don't name yourself
romeo man all right
uh so so this is
it it's very important like let's say in
terms of love it's especially in terms
of christian love
and especially in the way that you
understand how
love manifests itself in the church or
in the body of christ
there is proposition and reception
so this is actually true in the like
even in like the
liturgy so you have uh let's say the
priest
and then saying the prayer and then you
have the people
who say amen who say yes
and so you need both you need for sure
to have let's say the the
you can see it in different ways you
could see it as the man let's say
proposing right not necessarily
proposing to be married but proposing in
general
would you like to do something with me
would you you know would you like to go
out would you
we want to have coffee like uh and
sometimes it doesn't have to be that
much but it's just like
trying to talk to somebody and then
watching how they react
and and then you have to be attentive
to the answer right you have to be like
attentive to the yes or the no or the
maybe sometimes it's
it can be very kind of implicit uh but
those are the two elements that have to
kind of come together in order for
union to happen um and it doesn't
it doesn't have to be sentimental all
the time like we
the love stories we always always see it
as like just kind of like a
kind of a passion or or something that
is completely sentimental it doesn't
always have to be completely sentimental
especially as if you like if you ever
get married and you'll see after a while
then it's not so sentimental anymore at
some point
just becomes like a it becomes a more
kind of settled union and it's not as
it's not as obvious you don't have all
the same butterflies you do
um but i would say that that's that's it
and so what can you do
uh in terms of
attracting the other person and
sometimes you can't like sometimes you
won't be able to it's just
that's just how it is it's a difficult
reality
and so that will definitely that can
cause you to suffer
uh and that suffering
that suffering can be used as fuel if
you're if you're attentive
uh it can be used as fuel to become a
better person
um to become a better person in terms
just to make yourself more desirable to
the other to the opposite sex
uh but also make become a better person
in a more spiritual way
you know where that suffering can
actually that suffering of being
rejected in love uh can become
the type of suffering that can actually
lead you into a more spiritual attention
like more attentive attention to god and
to prayer
um and so it's like i'm not i don't want
to dis i don't want to just make this
sound easy it's not easy
enough none of this is easy um
but uh but uh but i i like yeah that's
that's
all i can say you know i would say
i would say for sure for sure
the capacity to to to
induce or to kind of bring about desire
in in another person
has more to do with you like it has more
to do with just
so if you if you're free
and you and you are confident
um not in a not in an excessive way but
like if you have
if you're free and you and you're
confident um
you know and you kind of like what
jordan peterson says like you just stand
straight and you look in front of you
and you
you you kind of go into the world then
that is something that will help to make
you more
to make you more desirable but um but
there's no easy no easy there's no easy
answer um
and so yeah and it's the same with the
other side like a woman can
be find be attracted to a man and then
desire to seduce him you know not
necessarily in it
not just like not in a not in like an
explicit necessarily vulgar way but in
subtle ways to
to kind of attract his attention to kind
of try to get
that that man to give his attention to
her
um and uh and uh and that also needs to
be reciprocated
or else at some point there's a there's
a limit right
there's a limited which you have to kind
of say okay this isn't gonna this is
gonna work so
yeah so good luck i wish you the best
man that's it's a tough time
i understand
all right so enrico says there are a lot
of numbers that seem to have meaning and
are occurring all the time in scriptures
i often skip them and don't pay
attention to them
are there any good uh author's book
sources that read that
uh that deal with this i know there is a
lot of numerology and new aegis stuff
out there
i'm looking for something grounded and
within tradition
i don't think i'm not aware of a book
that i would suggest to you that would
be like a
like a reading of numbers in scripture
directly
i mean it's out there but i don't know
if i know of a book that i can think of
like that
out of my head i'm sorry about that but
the problem with a lot of these books on
numbers is that a lot of them just kind
of
kind of make it up and so that's the
problem with sometimes people who talk
about symbolism is that just because you
just because people say that something
means something doesn't necessarily mean
that it does
and so i find very i'm often very
unsatisfied with
uh people and do who do uh
number interpretations that's maybe why
i don't do it so much in my
on my channel i mean i do have i feel
like i have an understanding of of
certain
basic uh basic number symbolism
but uh yeah
um and so susan martin said some very
nice things
um thank you susan and then she asked if
i read the works
of christopher alexander particularly
his book a pattern
language look
it is on my list
it definitely as you have so many people
have told me that i need to read that
book and so it's definitely on my list
it's a it's uh i haven't i haven't it's
in my amazon shopping cart let's say i
haven't yet
gotten it or my in my wish list or
whatever uh so no i haven't gotten it
yet but a lot of people have told me
that i need to read
his book um and then someone and then
she says it would be great to maybe
having him
in a video discussion i don't know if
he's still giving talks i'm not even
sure
uh is he's i don't know is he is still
alive i don't even know is he
if he's still giving talks it would be
great but i have thought that i would
probably need to read a few of his books
first
but both like many orthodox people
including andrew gould
uh um who else
there was someone else benedict sheehan
and several people have said you
need to read uh christopher alexander
and today i was
actually uh i was doing an interview
with uh
with rafe what's his last name he's a
he's a youtu he's a youtuber but he's
also a parkour guy
um and uh he was asking about the same
thing so yes so you guys are all pushing
me i will read
christopher alexander's book i just need
to find it i always need to find a pdf
version so i can listen to the audio
because i don't read anything now that
isn't uh
that isn't audio pretty much
um so conor says when you come across
people the old testament who lived for
hundreds of years
methuselah lived to six hundred uh 969
how are we supposed to understand this
is it to be taken literally
symbolically or a combination of the two
did mankind lose the grace of such
longevity
at any particular point in history um
i don't know what to tell you it's like
i would just take it for what's there
it's
you know it's the the narrative
seems to imply that there's a difference
between
before the flood and after the flood and
one of those differences is that
people people would edge up to a
thousand years
and so you can see how that is extremely
symbolic uh because a thousand years is
kind of like
plenitude and so you can see how nobody
reaches a thousand
and everybody comes close to a thousand
so you can imagine that it's a sign of
the fall
the fact that they don't go up to a
thousand
um they come close but they don't and so
it's a sign of the fall which then is
increased
in after the flood where the
where life is shortened far far more
short
and so you can see it as a continuation
of the
of the of the fall
into the second stage you could say and
so you could understand that
let's say when in revelation it says you
know that christ will reign for a
thousand years that's what it's talking
about
this is what it's a the type of
symbolism that it's alluding to in the
old testament
which is that that that men came
closer to living for the millennium uh
but they didn't quite make it so that's
that's what i think
so scotty thorpe asks what is the
symbolism of a light bulb
why do we use it as an inter
representation of an idea
subtly asking about the news yes well i
mean
yeah that's what it is it's like you're
right why do we see it as a
representation of ideas because that's
how we
experience having an idea or an insight
you know
we even say in sight it's like this idea
of
a seeing in or this flash we experience
it as a flash as a spark as
a as a glowing uh they're they're all
and light is definitely
one of the greatest ways to represent
that and so the idea of
you know the light bulb appearing above
the head is pure genius there's
that you know it's so funny that i'm
going to say this but like
cartoons especially like the early
cartoons kind of like looney tunes
cartoons and
those those kind of early cartoons
they're actually quite amount there's a
lot of symbolism in there
it's and a lot of it a lot of the tropes
that
were developed in those times like that
for example like a light bulb appearing
above the head or uh
you know these these kinds of uh of of
tropes
are really quite powerful in terms of uh
in terms of symbolism like even you know
the angel on the
on the one shoulder and the devil on the
other soldier that really took a lot of
that really kind of took shape in these
old cartoons um
yeah there's quite a bit in there to
think about it'd be interesting to
to think about that more
um so mika mueller asked what is the
symbolism of psychedelics
i'm gonna start getting those questions
all the time is this a totally new thing
or an old battle
we have forgotten any recommended
orthodox reading on the matter would be
greatly appreciated
and so uh it's like what's the symbol of
psychedelics it's it's uh it's
from a chaos it's a it's related to it's
related to
to to to kind of to magic
and to you know it's like i
how can i say it it's like i mean if you
listen to my videos recently you'll see
that i i don't want to speak out i don't
want to speak against it
completely because i have met people
that have said they have
in psychedelics kind of was a transition
for them
towards uh towards the spiritual life
and so
so i could i don't want to knock knock
it completely in the sense that i
understand
how people who are completely
materialist could be jolted into
seeing something more through this type
of experience
but what i'm seeing happen now
is rather people who see psychedelics
as a as uh as spirituality itself
or they see psychedelics as you know a
kind of uh solution to the problem of
meaning or
they see psychedelics as something which
will bring about
a spiritual transformation in the world
and if that's the case then i would say
absolutely not i don't think that that
that we
will do that at all it will participate
in the breakdown is what it's going to
do just like it did
in the 1960s which brought about more
chaos
more breakdown because if it's true that
psychedelics can connect you
to the invisible patterns or to the
invisible world
then if you do that without being
initiated without being ready
then you won't you won't be able to
distinguish what you're seeing
because in the world of patterns is also
all the monsters are all there too all
the
gargoyles and so you go into it if you
take a psychedelic and then you
you end up facing a gargoyle but you
don't you don't have the capacity
to differentiate an angel from a demon
and you and you and so you just go there
wide-eyed like a [ __ ] and then you
end up having a massively bad influence
an intelligence impregnate you know kind
of uh print itself on you in a in a
negative way and so
so it's like i said i i that's why i'm
always careful not to like knock it
completely because i
you know like who am i to say and i also
know that like i
really have met people who have been
have had
their first step on the road was through
that type of experience but
like i said i don't definitely don't see
it anybody who talks to you
in a way that they seem to speak as if
this is some kind of uh
solution to the problem that's the wrong
way to go about it
it's the wrong way all right so channel
attorney says what is the proper role of
gnosis
i found that my spiritual but not
religious peers are often seeking
experience
whether through movement practice
substances or meditation
i see in the world and feel in myself a
hunger for this but i don't know what
its proper place is
um so one of the one of the funny things
in terms of of uh
of gnosis is that uh
saying you know saying uh irenaeus of
leon wrote a book a famous book
against the gnostics and his book
is actually called uh it's like
treaties against the so-called gnostics
because
the the the contention of sandy
hernandez is that christians are the
true gnostics
christianity is true gnosis because
gnosis
in a in a christian sense is an
integration and so
knowledge in the biblical sense is like
a sexual union it's a it's a
meeting of heaven and earth whereas the
gnostics in the ancient sense
had an idea that it's like an escape of
reality
so you actually like escape you have to
escape your body you have to escape
reality
but you have to kind of rise up above it
um and that is kind of that is not at
all what the christians believe and so
the idea of of
seeking experience you shouldn't be
seeking experience you should be seeking
transformation
and transformation there will be
experiences that will come with that
transformation
but the experiences are like are these
fleeting things that you can have and
they'll go away and
if they don't leave if spiritual
experiences don't lead to transformation
then they're
hogwash then they're they're they're
nothing uh but
if you have little insights little
experiences in prayer or
in in practices and those those
experiences lead you towards
deep more towards transformation to
become
a better person to be to be less prone
to fall into your passions into your
your desires and that's the that's the
real beginning of
a path um and so i feel like a lot of
people
especially like again with the
psychedelics it's like people are just
looking to get
the the experience
um and they don't necessarily
then embody they don't embody a
transformational
uh path and like i said i've met people
that have and
and that's amazing when if that if that
happens like whatever
brings you to to to actually look to
christ
and to to to be transformed and that's
wonderful but
yeah so i don't i'm not most of the
church fathers really speak very
negatively about experience
nonetheless recognizing that experience
is
is act is part of it like that that
saints have
mystical experiences they have ex states
of ecstasy
all of this happens to the saints but
that's not what they're looking for
they're looking
to be transformed and in love into the
person of christ
so all right all right so we're done
with uh patreon
and uh so i'm gonna go into subscribe
star
so look at me i started at eight
i'm gonna still finish at 11 is what's
going to happen it's going to be just
going to be a longer q and a is what's
going to happen
uh so so xrd asks
an idea struck me while listening to
your talk with paul king's north
the enlightenment has been like adam and
eve eating the fruit on a societal scale
society was promised that reason would
make us good without god yes exactly
comparable to the snake's promise of
godhood and since then we've
been stuck in a further protracted fall
with smaller falls within
communism sexual revolution etc any
thoughts of that
yes you're completely right your insight
is absolutely
straight on it's that's exactly what it
is and you could
say that
let's say the pride in the garden
because it's a sin of pride that
is happening right the desire to take
the fruit for yourself
uh is also the pride of man
in the enlightenment you know and it's
like it it
it's tricky for people to understand
because yes like the human person is the
jewel of creation
and god made us into the highest aspect
of creation
but it's something that we receive and
it's something that we have to not take
for ourselves or to
kind of sit on our own to sit on that
reality and to think that that's the
totality of everything
um because then that's the fall that's
always the fall
and uh and you're right and so you can
see how
it's funny because you see it like if
you listen to if you watch
if you read uh like stephen pinker and
all these people
i love how they talk about the counter
enlightenment i just love it because
it's like there's the enlightenment and
then there's the counter enlightenment
you don't realize how the entering into
the duality
is what gave those two at the same time
one is a mirror of the other you can't
have one without the other like you
can't have uh
enlightenment without the dark side
let's say so
especially in the way they phrase
enlightenment like this reason
reason has light and so here comes the
dark side
anyways so that's kind of funny all
right so
we are we are actually done with all the
corrections let me go
into the super chats
like never ready for the for the super
chats i always almost like forget
how how to get into them
right here we go okay
whoa there are a lot of super chats oh
my goodness
did i just have a southern accent there
okay
so here we go
uh so uh here we go steve steve uh
steve bedford for five usd
thank you for your work jonathan could
you explain the symbolism of why only
men
can be priests um
so let me just give me a second because
someone said there are two more
questions on patreon
so you guys have to also not uh not
try not to put in the questions like
during the question here that doesn't
work really well
um okay so
can you spend a symbolism on of why only
men could can be priests and so it has
to do with this
it's a cosmic structure so you
understand that
there's a function like there's a
function of
male uh of of masculine and feminine
and it's akin to to heaven and earth
and so there's a there's a series of
analogies
that play themselves out and so
the the priest in the analogy let's say
so you
think about it this was you have heaven
and earth and then you have like god
and the temple let's think about it in
the in the old testament if it
may be easier for you so you have god
and
the the temple and then you have
the glory of god and the ark of the
covenant
and then you have the ark of the
covenant
and the priest and then you have the
priest
and the people right and so these are
all masculine feminine
relationships all the way through so you
have god
you have say god in all of creation then
you have like heaven and earth or god
manifesting himself towards in god in
heaven
manifesting himself towards the earth
then the temple again this dual
relationship
then the glory on the ark male female
then the
ark or the glory of the ark together
towards the priest male female
then the priest turns becomes is male
towards
the people and then the people are
feminine okay and so and so the
role of the priest like in incarnated in
the
in the in the is masculine and so
because of that
then priests are masculine and the the
people
or the they we those
we play a a feminine role in
receiving and that becomes more feminine
but then it it keeps playing itself out
like in a family father
wife you know husband wife husband wife
and kids
you know all of this keeps playing out
but it's it's like it's
it's that masculine and feminine or not
it's not a moral question
it's a it's a structural reality that
that's how
it works and this is a structural
reality which was carried
into christianity so it's not just like
people say
it's just a cultural thing it's just uh
it's just
it's not just a cultural thing it's a
structural symbolic
cosmic structure and so
then so it's not about so it's like
so christians have always believed that
men and women are equal
let's say equal in value or equal in
nature but they do play a different
role in structurally and that different
role structurally has a form and that's
that's it that's the form that it that
it plays um
that's that's as good as it's going to
get for me
uh so louis gerard says why did david
slay goliath with a sling
instead of a sword or a spear
um it has
so he actually did he did did a few
things he did he actually also
uh killed goliath in part with a sword
but let's talk about this thing first so
the sling has to do with
so the sling has to do with something
like using
using the margin against itself and so
you know i talk about this idea of like
the the
the monster on the edge and
david is also that but in a different
has a different type of symbolism to
that
david is the youngest son he's the last
son he's little he's small and so
so uh goliath is big and so
there's something about that so what he
does is he takes these rocks and he puts
them in a sling and he turns them
right and so he spins and the now the
rock is on the edge right it's
it's it's like turn using the power of
the periphery
and then finally the one that gets that
gets lost like breaks free
goes off and then uh then
kills the kills the the giant and so
it it's something about using the
periphery against itself
something about
turning the turning the you know i talk
about how king david also has something
of
the fool who becomes king and so there's
something of that in what he's doing
using this this sling movement uh
and and and uh yeah
there's something about that
um okay so
so john schultz barnes for 10 usd says
i'm pressured to work to get the vaccine
man
any advice on what to say to employers
to explain 666 related reservations
without
sounding crazy
man i don't know i don't know what to
say it's it's very
it's it's tough you're in a tough
situation um
i don't have like i don't have a
straight up solution for you i would say
i don't think like this is something
some people will disagree
with me and uh like i really don't think
that
uh that the vaccine
right now the way it's presented to us
is like
is exactly the mark of the beast or
something like that
uh i think it's heading in that
direction
i think that we're heading in that
direction but i don't think it's there
quite yet um
and so that's something to think about
and so i am definitely like i can tell
you guys here
i am going to wait as much as possible
and avoid it as much as possible and
watch
as much as possible just watch and see
what happens and see how it plays out
um but i don't
so that's all i can tell you and so i
don't know how i wouldn't know
i don't not sure how i'd react
to to the situation but um
sorry you're in that man i'm gonna i'm
going to
put out my videos like the videos that
i'm gonna put out in the next the next
two videos are going to be
trying to help people figure out that
the relationship between
between the mark the mark of cain the
mark of the beast
and the the medical
situation like in terms of the idea of
uh
of a poison that is a cure or the the
idea of a vaccine too so i'm going to
talk
about that but it's not um yeah
man all right so alex carris says
sorry about my tech failure for 20 he
says that i'm so sorry no worries man we
got
better now like now we had the actual
microphone which is much better
um so grum meister for ten dollars
australian
what is the symbolism of good omens
it seems to be something to do with uh
no heaven and hell
being a good thing but i can't figure
out
oh what you mean good omens like the the
the series the the tv series
um
so okay so i can tell you what i think
gaiman was trying to do because i didn't
watch the good omens
um
i think what gaiman tried to do in good
omens was
to to resolve opposites that's what he
was hoping to do
so you see because you see it play out
at different levels
you see how there's a
there's a sense in which so if you
understand
if you understand the angels as you
understand the characters is not
necessarily angels or demons
but if you understand the characters in
the way they present themselves
which is the angel as like a goody
two-shoes
that is like a fop
you know it's kind of like a is is not
is not embodied you know it's just a is
is is a it's kind of a yeah it's a fop i
don't know what else to say that's what
he's like
um and then this like kind of bad
embodied you know uh let's say um
more rebellious type and so what it
seems like what he's trying to do
is to show how to kind of how those two
can work on each other
in order to come closer to the middle
and so he seems to play that all through
the series
and he also seems to do it uh with the
idea of like the witch hunter and the
witch
who actually kind of fall in love and
you can see it at different levels
how this this kind of plays out um
um but it but ultimately you know i
think that
just like so many things someone at some
of this stuff is that obviously
because it is dealing with heaven and
hell and angels and
and um and demons it is
just like all of gaiman's work let me
tell you what the problem with gaming's
work is
is that he acts as if he believes in
principalities
but he doesn't he thinks principalities
are arbitrary
he doesn't actually think that the lord
of dream is the lord of dreams he thinks
the lord of dreams is just some guy who
happens to be the lord of dreams
and he could change like he could be
something else he could be free from his
own
principality it's like he could see it
in the image of lucifer like his image
of lucifer gaiman's image of lucifer
is the most is the most absurd idea
right it's like lucifer decides that
he's done with this
and he's going to cut his wings off and
he's going to be free from his own
cosmic role and it's like that's what
gaiman's work
all of his work is about it he's a he's
a he's a
he's a he's a post-modern guy he's a
he's a modern guy he doesn't
he's a materialist actually he's a he's
a revolutionary he's all that stuff he
doesn't believe
that these principalities are real and
so
and so his work is fascinating because
he seems to have a
he has some insights like sometimes i
think that he has some good insights
but in the end those fall apart because
he
he wants to treat principalities as
idiosyncrasies
as idiosyncratic beings that somehow
happen to be that
and it doesn't work it sometimes makes
for
for interesting stories but it doesn't
it ends up falling apart and so
so yeah sorry
i didn't expect anything myself to like
go on a rant against neil gaiman
he's he's still like he's some story
still like you can see
like i i have read american gods and i
have watched good omens and i've
read the the sandman series so it's not
like i'm okay
obviously i have like a weird attraction
to what he's doing because i feel like
he could come close to something but he
oh he never really does he just
comes up to it and then here comes the
materialist like here comes the
here comes the arbitrary nihilist in in
the story so
yeah all right
all right so how would you differentiate
meekness versus being cowardly and weak
i've always had a problem with the word
meek i mean i can't
how can i say this it's like i can't i
can't you can know in yourself
that's the only way you can know right
you can know in yourself if you're
attentive you have to be honest with
yourself and be attentive to yourself
you can see whether or not you're acting
out of
out of meekness or out of cowardice it's
it feels very different
when you do one or another um
all right
so meebla says i recall hearing that a
big influence on your wife coming closer
to christ was the movie braveheart could
you expand on that love that movie
um so i mean in the case of my wife i
think that what
made her with mid braveheart kind of uh
part of her spiritual path was how
she saw that braveheart um
that the the william wallace was
completely dedicated to what he was
doing
and was willing to suffer for
what he believed and what he you know
what he wanted
in and he submitted himself to a higher
goal and so it's like that higher goal
within god but you can
kind of transpose that and understand
how
we compromise all the time you know be
you know in our faith and compromise
for this dumbest reason uh whereas you
you can see
in braveheart this capacity to
be fully given and dedicated and i think
that's what really
touched her um
let's see what how did i okay so
john schultz barnes says for ten dollars
any advice
for someone
i think you just asked that question
about the the the vaccine yeah sorry
maybe i'm i'm like
reading the same questions twice uh
gabriel torres says to knowledge is
there any symbolic meaning attributed to
dead birds
i mean it depends like i know what if i
had a dead
if i would put a dead bird in a story i
would know what that would mean it would
mean
like uh something like like a fallen
principality
you know or like a failed uh
principality
like if i put a bird dead bird in a
story that's what that's what i would be
alluding to
like it depends like you could also
imagine like let's say shooting a bird
like with a with a gun with an arrow um
could be yeah it could be seen like a
kind of uh
like a kind of revolution or something
in a story
i think i'm being confused in my in the
way that i'm doing this okay so alex
cares vitalis
i'm sorry about the mic failure no
worries it's fine
uh v2 zooey for 10 chf says i struggle
to understand why you think
the christian story is inevitable the
world makes as much sense if we posit
god's existence but without positing the
incarnation
the meaning would still be there
uh
so there are two things like i would say
that when i say that
usually i i do say that
post-incarnation is that once the
incarnation
has happened the christian story
becomes inevitable and this kind of
plays itself
out especially in the west
where we have no other story
and so there nothing has happened it's
like we're waiting for the return of
christ you could say
so in this in the christian story this
is actually one of the great things
about the christian story
that in the christian story it sets up a
pattern in which
it tells you what the next thing is
like it tells you what's the next thing
that has to happen
for the story to change and now
and so it actually sets that up it's
like it says
because the thing about it about about
the story you live in is that you're not
completely in control of it things have
to happen
like things happen people appear on the
horizon like someone has to come up
and and so it's like you you could say
for example like you could say
um like you could say something like
what america needs to do is to change
this or that or change this or that or
change it to that
but unless there's someone who comes up
who rises up
and has the the the presence and the
authority and the influence to
bring about that change then you can
blah blah blah all you want
it's not gonna happen and so imagine now
that for like the biggest story ever
is you can say it's like well we don't
need jesus we could kind of
get around it and we could do other
things but that's the story you've got
and so unless unless antichrist
comes and christ comes back
in a in the total way or in a small way
that's the story we're in there is no
other story
that you can really participate in
it's like it's almost like i i what i'm
telling you is so immediate that i'm not
sure
everybody really gets it it's like
it's as simple as saying that
you could like the story of harry potter
better than your life
you could you could think it would be
great if you could live in harry potter
land where you would go to
hogwarts and be and become one of the
students there
but that's not your life that's not your
story you're in a story you're in
there is a story happening and even if
you can try to like try to imagine that
you would like something else to be true
that's not what's there and so
yeah so i don't know like it to me to me
i feel
i feel when i talk about this like i
said is that sometimes i feel like
it's so immediate what i'm telling you
is so immediate that i think
people can't see it uh so
all right sorry about that g2
all right so mj says can you explain the
symbolism of baphomet
and also the depiction of two angels
kneeling before him
um
so i talk about this
a little bit i kind of allude to the
symbolism of baphomet in
the uh in the the montero video
slightly i don't know if i don't go into
it completely but you can understand it
as uh
could understand it as something which
was projected into the imagination
in the 11th century uh when the
templars were disbanded
was it 11th or 12th i'm not sure anyways
when the
temple the temples were disbanded
there's an image that was kind of
projected into the imagination which
became
like an image of the opposite of
christianity or the
desacralization of christianity and so
that image started to grow
to a point where it started to be
actually taken up by people
even though i don't think at first i
think at first it was just a slander
it started to be taken up to a point
where it became an ideal
that was used in magical theory
in the 19th century obviously by
elephants livi and by
crowley and by all of these occultists
and so
what you see in the image of baphomet is
you can see
the difference you get so you can
understand it's like the difference
between
syncretism and synthesis so christ
is an image of synthesis in which
dualities
are in the image of christ so it's like
i've talked about this like
the the blessing finger in the book the
two eyes
the the the inner garment the outer
garment this duality is there in the
image of christ
and you even have let's say if you think
about the image of christ with the
four cherubs you even have an aspect of
hybridity
in the corners in the edges but all of
this is brought together
in unity and so it's an actual union of
heaven and earth
so when the occultists say you know uh
as above uh whatever it's like
as above so below that's actually what
christ does
like really that's what christ does but
their image like an image of baphomet
is actually an image of confusion it's
an image of hybridity it's an image of
monstrosity
and that's why it presents itself that
way and so
so baphomet is is not is a
is a uh is a is a hermaphrodite
baphomet is a is a half human half
man so they see it as the people who
produce that say it as well it's a union
of opposites but there
there are unions of opposites which are
confused using union of opposites
and there are unions of opposite which
are synthetic and
and that that's the difference between
baphomet
and christ which is why you could say
that baphomet is
an antichrist image in a very strict and
simple way
because it is the it is
it is the difference between
unity and multiplicity multiplicity in
unity
in true unity and confusion and mixture
on the other side so that's what i think
and i think that the upside down
pentagram uh
is an image of that so you some of you
have probably seen i did a video on the
upside down pentagram
for patrons only and in that video
that's kind of what i explained it's
like
what why is this upside down pentagram
because it has to do with this worship
of multiplicity and this kind of
seeing the unity of in how can i say
this to see
unity emanating from multiplicity rather
than
let's say the other way around so
there'd be a lot more to say obviously
but i don't want to also spend too much
attention on that
freak figure
all right so brian j for five dollars
hey jp what's the symbolism of
celebration
why do we evaluate the difference in
meaning between say a baptism
and a gender reveal party
uh well celebration is great there's the
celebration is about
is has is a it's a smaller version um
[Music]
it's like a little venerating or it's
like little worship it's not it's not a
bad it's good the sense that you you
come together to recognize something
which is worth celebrating um and so
that's why we have celebration of saints
the way birthdays all of this is good
it's good stuff because it
it celebrations are the way we we are
bind
the way that we're bound together you
know um
so they're great and what's the
difference between uh baptism and a
gender reveal party i mean it's just a
just a difference of level obviously a
baptism is is a higher
than a gender reveal party but i think
that
the fact that people do these gender
reveal parties is
is a is a shows you that the ancient
celebrations which we've tried to
evacuate because we think that they're
meaningless and superstitious are
nonetheless coming back in all these
kind of
superficial and secondary ways but
there's nothing wrong with a gender
reveal party
but it's obviously on a very low much
lower level than something like
a baptism so
so judex for ten dollars says that you
made a video talking about
your saint michael and the dragon i
bought a t-shirt
a sweatshirt and would like to know more
about what i'm wearing
i don't think i made a video
specifically about michael and the
dragon
that could be an interesting video to
make actually it could be
it could be uh i mean it's it's i feel
like it's
it's so funny because sometimes like
that like i feel like it's it's like
it's obvious what that's about
and so maybe that's why i don't talk
about it but it i mean it's just heaven
and earth
in the in the sense of earth as chaos
and then and then heaven
kind of that's a re-imposing order
on on earth as chaos let's say
um but i would be maybe a good idea
maybe that's something i could do at
some point
um so alex karis for 20 years d without
going into how differently we
view symbolism in western post
enlightenment what do you figure is the
best way to explain to fundamentalists
not to take genesis literally but
instead symbolically
um
that word literal man it bothers me okay
so
let's use another word just to help
ourselves because
what what do you figure is the best way
to explain the to fundaments not to take
genesis
scientifically but rather to take it
literally literally i i don't like that
word because i don't use it but
literally just means what's written in
the text that's what literal means
literal means
literary it doesn't mean scientific this
is also
i mean i've fallen into that tribe
before which is that i i said there's no
literal but
it's like literal in the sense of this
neutral this neutral reality
literal means what's in the text so you
really do need to take what's in the
text in that sense like
what's in the text is is what's what's
being told to you
but i think that to me the best way to
to maybe um help people understand that
is that is to maybe help them see that
by doing that by trying to read genetic
genesis
scientifically or historically in the
way we understand historically now like
as critical
history let's say uh is
actually to worship that like you're
actually
when you want to think that genesis is a
scientific text
it means that you actually worship
science because that text is obviously
not
that and not only is it not that but
it's okay that it's not that
and the fact that you think that it's
not okay the fact that it bothers you
that it's not a scientific description
means that you have your priorities in
the wrong order
because science is not god so
take what's there actually and just
interpret what's there
and don't try to don't try to
bring it into a field that it doesn't
have that doesn't have room for so
and the next thing is to show them just
how much
just to show them how much that story is
like the source of all the other stories
and it
it's actually more like uh like an
origin story
that that then is causal to all the
other stories in scripture
i think that's maybe the best way to to
do it um
um all right
okay so die dan diego de la vega says
what are your thoughts on nietzsche as a
philosopher
i i don't know nishi's one of those
people that you kind of have sympathy
for
because he was dealing with really
superficial christianity
but you also don't have sympathy for
because
because he was because his his i think
his vision is wrong
i think he's wrong you know and and i
think that
he is the his
he bore the fruit of how he was wrong
let's just say it that way
um so mika harding says
five usd is there a relationship between
the snake of the garden and the concept
of tantra
or kundalini i have no idea i don't i
don't
i especially that whole kundalini thing
never really interested me
i always felt like it was fake that
kundalini stuff
it was like a kind of weird new age
thing all right so radio teaching for 20
years the ask you should look at you
should look into the relationship
between the alchemical quest for the
philosopher's stone
and bitcoin along with the metaphysical
underpinning of it all
interesting i think about that
i definitely should think about that in
terms of the the relationship between
bitcoin and the philosopher's thorn
philosopher's stone or bitcoin and the
and the the grail maybe even
it's definitely something to think about
i'm not i don't think i'm done
with bits with bitcoin and so uh like
i i need to find someone because uh
robert reedlove i really enjoyed my
conversation with him he was really
great
um but he was definitely a proponent of
bitcoin like he was definitely
uh sold to the idea and so it ended up
being more like
like you know i was arguing with not
arguing but i was like discussing with
someone who is completely for it and so
it would be nice for me to find someone
who is
knowledgeable about bitcoin has thought
about it and maybe is not
is is more like let's say
has a can we can see different sides of
it let's say or can
can see the advantages and disadvantages
of it and could be willing to talk about
it so
so hopefully hopefully you can see
so lisa parrott says hello friends lisa
you just appear in the chat
at this time what's going on how late is
it for you
it's like super late for you did you
just like wake up maybe at least i just
woke up maybe
um anyways
all right okay so brian k uh for fire
valley says
could a new form of literally be found
in the alternative
alliterative and mythological symbolism
of modern storytelling through exodus
uh parallel stories
um i'm not sure i understand like
what alliterative symbolism is in modern
storytelling i'm not sure
i understand
i would say like also yeah i think it's
important to understand that you really
can't have
a proper liturgy out of something which
is fictional
and it's kind of understood to be
fictional um
it has to be a story that you can that
you can participate in in
a very immediate way so it's like
the crowning of a king can have a
liturgical
aspect you know or even even uh
like the the swearing-in of a president
is actually liturgical
or um a birthday party
is liturgical but that's because it's
actually a participation in in uh
in reality right it's a it's a it's a
it's
bringing in a pattern so that a
particular moment participates
in that pattern but
uh like forming liturgies out of fiction
would not would not have any would not
have
would would be superficial like they
wouldn't really connect
all the levels together
so marino alexander says what's the
symbol of mirror bearing
icons specifically the panagia why do we
think of them as crying
and usually not sweating or bleeding
interesting well i mean it does it has
to do with the idea of compassion
uh and so it's like you can understand
that the compassion of the mother of god
is a perfume like it has a good odor
it's like a
it's a it's a it's a it's a sacrifice
and so it's like offered to god and so
just like these sweet uh
beer these sweet uh oils were like
were used in a kind of offering
i think that that's probably what's
going on
so bing binger for ten dollars says
hello jonathan i was wondering what are
the comparisons between gnostic
christianity and freemason
luciferian religion they seem similar in
some parts especially
the promethean aspect um
i would say at least i mean the
gnosticism that i understand it would be
kind of the opposite of
of uh of nas of like luciferian
vision or promethean vision at least the
traditional gnostics
they had a sense that they had to escape
the world but maybe like maybe you're
right maybe
the idea of of the promethean project or
the modern promethean project
especially like the the the technology
as
supposedly creating a transhuman state
then in that sense i do believe that
maybe it has something to do with
gnosticism
um so yeah so maybe there's a connection
but it's it's not it's not
straightforward i would say
there's more a relationship between kind
of luciferian
vision that you see today and the enoch
like the book of enoch that for sure
in terms of the watchers and all that
stuff like that is definitely very close
so abraham matthews 400 inr
says can you make a video or blog on
your thoughts regarding mr mitho's video
on yahweh
i don't know i've never seen that i'd
have to like check that out
who's mr mythos i don't think i even
know who he is
so paul froelich ten dollars for just
ten dollars thanks paul
matt for 4.99 thoughts on laying of
hands traditionally
one with authority does this uh bishop
priest charismatically hands on one
another
yeah it's i mean it's about it's about
so think about it like uh
okay so think about it like you you have
you have your pattern you have your
your will or your thoughts or whatever
and usually
you you embody that how do you embody
that you usually embody it with your
hands like
the things you do most of the things you
do are done with your hands
when you work you you know you greet
people all of this is
his hands so hands are let's say
the place where you transfer power to
the world
and so it makes total sense that that
that spiritually like that one of the
ways that you can manifest the transfer
of authority into the into something
else would be by putting your hands on
it
because that's what you do all the time
like when you when you're
when you're building a house like in
your hammering nails
you're transferring your authority into
power of you with your hands to like
manifest that pattern in the world
and so that's the same with like this
idea of laying of hands it's the
yeah all right so ma michael river for
five dollars what do you think will
happen when we get rid of aging
permanent liturgical celebration
hopefully preferably orthodox
i don't think that's gonna happen
they're not in this world
uh
all right the golden thread for a
hundred dollars oh my goodness when
young i thought eternity was infinite
time
clearly it's qualitatively different
than our time it has implications for
what it is
like to be a bad angel principality so
it's even listening to father stephen
can you expand on eternity in relation
to the ontology of divine beings
where to read more and so so you
you kind of you you have to unders the
way to understand eternity is something
like akin to the center of a space
so imagine that you have a
a circle and
the circle has a center right
so the center actually
doesn't exist in in the circle
the the center is actually virtual it's
a it's a virtual point
it doesn't take up any space right it is
it's like an invisible point invisible
in the sense that it doesn't have
dimension
but nonetheless it is the center
it is that out of which the circle
emanates and it's that out of which
uh the circle uh how can i say this the
circle
is identified or finds its common place
so all the all the the spokes of the
wheel let's say
on the on the circle all the spokes all
the radii the indefinite radii from the
center to the
to the to the periphery all joined
together
in that invisible point that has
no that has no no
dimension and so that's what
eternity is to time so
eternity is the place where all time is
resolved
out of which all time finds its
extension
but it doesn't have duration it is
without duration and it's it's actually
because it doesn't have duration
that it becomes the synthesis
and origin of all time
and so that's the best way to understand
it it's like you're not going to totally
understand
eternity but that at least is the way
that i
can even approach it is to understand it
in analogy to
to um to space but in time now
so darren for 20 usd says i've come to
terms with mature abandoning us
moving forward have you ever considered
bringing on a certain
french canadian professional
skateboarder i'd love to hear a normal
person's thought about this
his two insane brothers that's hilarious
so for people who don't know
my brother dan dan pedro uh
was a uh was a french canadian
professional skateboarder so for
for several years he skated for some of
the big companies in the us
and he lived in long beach and did the
skater lifestyle
and he is now actually now uh he's
actually up
like a pentecostal pastor in uh near
vancouver
and he's uh super involved he runs a
like a thrift shop
to help kind of uh single moms and to
to kind of help the the community there
he's uh he's great
i don't know if he'd even be interested
in coming on my channel
it's like i should ask him i should ask
dan if you'd be interested in
my channel i don't think he would be i
think he'd i think
i don't know i'd ask him um but
as for matsir like i would say don't
totally abandon hope
you might you might have some surprises
there might be some surprises
i can't promise anything but there might
be some surprises all right so federal
libraries for 10
usd says what is the symbolism of the
will
that's a that's a big question dude that
i'm not going to answer that attention
11 sorry federal libraries and then he
asks another question which is
what is the symbolism of symbolism and
so
uh the symbolism of symbolism is that
it's symbolism
you're gonna start getting crazy answers
if you ask that kind of stuff at like
10 to 11. all right grum meister for 10
for five dollars
australian narcissism hinduism and
zoroastrianism
they try to achieve union with higher
reality
what is that reality so you can unders
christianity also tries to achieve union
with a higher reality
um uh it's just that it doesn't
christianity does it in an in uh you
know
at least compared to gnosticism uh
hinduism is very varied so it's
difficult
to to to say hinduism but you know it
does it through incarnate to an
incarnational principle which contains
the multiplicity let's say
and so that higher reality is uh is is
god or is
non-duality or is the is is the place
where
multiplicity is the infinite
yeah but i think god is the best way
to talk about it
uh all right let me just see because i
see there are still some things coming
in here
uh let's see all right so
okay so two more questions on patreon mr
j
i will let me do those right now two
more questions on patreon
so the fellowship of bitcoin oh my
goodness
what does he ask it's going to be about
bitcoin do you think i think so
hi jonathan thank you for all the great
content uh can you
talk a bit about the potential
relationship between the alchemical
quest for the philosopher's stone and
the bitcoin
yes i mean maybe it's the same person
who asked it on on youtube
i would definitely have to think about
it i definitely have to think about it i
think there is something there
but i it's it's foggy it's like it's
foggy maybe because i don't understand
bitcoin well enough but it's definitely
foggy
but you you put me on a path so let's
see where that leads and let's see
um and so kenobi asked okay again the
symbolism of baphomet
so all right so so they ended up being
answered all these
uh so drew mcmahon for 499 is crying a
form of losing control the way laughing
is
jesus wept um
and so it depends so it depends
so crying and laughing can almost can
kind of be seen as opposite from each
other but
obviously they actually do meet in a
weird way but
you could if you understand crying in
the sense of
compassion then
there is a sense in which it's a
it's a giving up of control
right and letting yourself be touched
let's say by suffering or the suffering
of others let's say
and so it's different from
laughing because laughing
is a is a
laughing is a kind of inebriation
uh whereas weeping is more of a is an
entering into
like at least that's how this i'm just
saying this like that but that's
that's what i that's what i perceive
like when you cry
if you cry obviously you can cry for the
wrong reason but if you cry for good
reasons like if you cry
when you see when you cry when you
meditate on
on on the suffering of others um
then or if you cry if you
yeah i think that that's like an
entering in even if you cry for your own
suffering if you do it or if you cry for
your own lack of
of capacity to to embody let's say with
you cry out of
out of uh being contrite where you ask
forgiveness and you cry because you see
you're in capacity to to do the things
you want to do like your will is not
following you
then there's a kind of entering in uh
and it and laughing seems to be a kind
of distancing you know
like you kind of distance yourself at
least that's my intuition but you know i
need to think about that too
uh so frank ten dollars usd right before
communion i heard a prayer to the holy
spirit for it to turn the bread into the
body of christ
is the holy spirit the thing that helps
us see multiplicity of
objects part in unity
um
you could yeah you could kind of say
that you could you could say
that's a good weight that's not a it's
not a thing
the holy spirit is not a thing those
period is a person that's important uh
to distinguish but
in terms of understanding that there's
definitely a relationship
like that's why god blows his spirit
into
adam in order to give him life as he's
gathered the multiplicity into one and
that's why
um but there's all it actually seems to
be like a dual thing
this is these these do these they're
these
there are some of these symbolism that
are like the two extremes at the same
time
they're hard to think about that's why
actually the this video on the mark of
cain
is because the mark does opposite things
um
and so the holy spirit seems to be let's
say something like you said something
like
unity and multiplicity and so sometimes
it appears as
moving towards multiplicity and
sometimes it appears as moving towards
unity
and so let's say when christ blows onto
his disciples
and then he says like go out into the go
out and then the same at pentecost when
the holy spirit descends on the apostles
and then they start to speak
in all these different languages and so
now it then it seems to be like doing
the opposite of what it does
to to adam but it's actually the same if
you understand
that it's that which makes unity and
multiplicity come together
uh that the holy spirit does that
and so yeah that's as close as it's
gonna get
so cello guy for five dollars
uh five uh british pounds says is the
vaccine in the combination with cogan
copenhagen vaccine passport an example
of a manifestation of the pattern of the
mark of the beast and so
it's definitely coming very close to
that i think i mentioned that earlier in
the conversation
it's coming close i don't know if it's
that yet but it's definitely
that's def it's like it's like it's it's
really kind of
moving in that direction um and so
you'll see in my next videos about this
like i'm going to talk about this more
explicitly
try to avoid using certain terms because
because youtube
youtube is going to is gonna hate me if
i start talking about that stuff
so i'll just i'll be careful but if you
guys are
capable of listening and be flexible
enough to see that i'm avoiding certain
words just to
to kind of avoid uh being banned from
youtube then then hopefully you'll
understand
so does christ pre-incarnate have to be
all the physical embodiments of god the
father in the old testament
i don't know like are there embodiments
of god the father in the old testament i
don't think i
usually the church fathers see all the
theophanies as being christ
you know that's what i that's what i see
um so jp for five dollars what is the
symbolism of long hair on a man does it
have anything to do with spilling seed
um
no i don't think so the the long hair on
a man
at least like saint paul seems to talk
about long hair
on a man as being
problematic because it's like a it's
like a covering
and so that's how he seems to
to see it but there's also the idea of
long hair in the sense of of uh
purity and and uh not touching or not
bringing the knife to not not cutting
and so you see that
in the um in the symbolism
of the nazarenes um
[Music]
and so the the the the the nazarenes
would
would not cut their hair and so that's
why monks orthodox monks also have long
hair
it has to do with a vow um
to to to not cut your hair cut your
beard because it's like you just
you're you're you're it's like a kind of
purity
so it depends on the context i think
all right so i think this is gonna be
the last question guys so don't put in
any others because i i i'm pretty much
done i went
this is i it's like i put it at 8 and
now it's 11 so i always end it at 11.
i'm going to end 11 anyways
all right so peyton evans for 10 vsd
hello i'm interested in the sacramento
confession and the healing power of a
sincere apology do you have any thoughts
on these things i'm not well educated on
christianity my apologies
so yeah i mean the sacrament of
confession is wonderful
it's a it can really be it can really be
a healing
uh process especially if you have uh if
you find a priest that is uh
that is attentive and that listens and
take what you're saying seriously
it's uh it's a wonderful thing and so uh
but you need to you definitely need to
be in in the
in the tradition at least in the church
to to be able to uh
to participate in that but i think that
if you're not
yet or if you're moving towards the
church and you're not there yet
you know it's it's probably still
possible to
um to meet uh
to meet a priest or to meet someone who
has some kind of uh
spiritual authority and then ask them if
they'd be willing to
to hear you in terms of
in terms of whatever it is that you have
on your conscience like
that might that might be uh uh
might be a temporary bomb let's say
all right so normative for 14.99 says
interview vin armani on bitcoin no one
has a more unique take on it
and so i i made contact with vin
actually and we had a few exchanges on
uh
on uh on email and stuff and
uh and i think for now he said he'd
probably want to wait for a while before
he had because i think he's busy
doing a lot of stuff he's got a lot of
stuff on his plate and a lot of stuff
going on
so he said he'd rather not he said that
he really loves what i'm doing and that
he's a big fan of
of what i talk about and i've seen him
talk about me on on
like on twitter and stuff and so so i
believe him but he said he'd rather he'd
rather wait so we'll see who knows
maybe one day all right so um
thank you everybody this was this is
good sorry for the craziness at the
beginning
like 20 minutes of nothing uh uh and so
uh so thanks for thanks for all your
attention
and um yeah look next month i'll try to
do this at eight as well because i think
i think it's probably more active
there's more people that i think come on
when i'm a little earlier so uh so all
right i will
log off and i will see everybody next
month thanks everybody bye-bye